ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. AND THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. I AGREE ARE
CURRY. ARAMBULA OUR QUE EN
BERMAN BIGELOW. BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA LOW BURKE
CALDERON RIO CERVANTES CHAO IN
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DEEP EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL. GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LEE MODE
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REEBOKS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH STONE DEAN
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN REVEREND PATTY OSHA
RIVER NEXT. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
MOMENT OF REFLECTION. I COME TO
FEEL THAT THERE ARE DEEP
UNSPOKEN WONDERMENT THAT ALL
CHILDREN HAVE. THE WONDERMENT
BEGAN WHEN WE UNDERSTAND THAT
SOME DAY WE WILL GROW UP. WE
QUIETLY WONDER WHAT WILL MY
LIFE BE LIKE WILL I BE HAPPY.
WELL MY LIFE MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
THESE QUESTIONS REFLECT OUR
HOPE THAT WE WILL HAVE A GOOD
AND MEANINGFUL LIFE. IT WAS
ONLY AFTER RETIRING FROM ACTIVE
MINISTRY THREE YEARS AGO THAT
MY HUSBAND BOB AND I BEGAN TO
ASSESS OUR LIFE'S JOURNEY. WE
FOUND THE ONLY IN RETIRING DO
WE ALLOW OURSELVES THE TIME TO
LOOK BACK. IT HAS BEEN A
WONDERFUL LIFE. WE ARE GRATEFUL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE
HAD AN WE BOTH HAVE FEW REGRETS.
OUR LIVING LEGEND DOTSON WILSON
IS SOON RETIRING AFTER FOUR
DECADES OF SERVICE TO THE
ASSEMBLY AND SERVING ALMOST
THREE DECADES AS OUR CHIEF
CLERK IN PARLIAMENT TARIAN. HE
CANNOT HELP BUT LOOK BACK AND
KNOW THAT THE UNSPOKEN
WONDERMENT OF HIS YOUTH HAVE
BEEN FULFILLED. WELL I'D BE
HAPPY WELL MY LIFE MAKE A
DIFFERENCE WELL I HAVE A GOOD
IN MEANINGFUL LIFE. OF THAT
DOTSON THERE CAN BE NO DOUBT
AND WE WILL ALWAYS THINK OF YOU
WITH GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
NUMBER ONE THE NUMBER WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS. THANK YOU REVEREND WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING. AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES AND SHE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MYSTERY.
SURE HAND OVER YOUR HEART READY
TO BEGIN. THIS IS A. YEAH THANK
YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY JULY ELEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN EASILY REDDIT
NINETY AM THE AUDIBLE KEVIN
MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE THE
ASSEMBLY DECIDED TO THIRTY
DAWSON WAS IN THE DESK READING
HER DEFINITELY MOVES MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS AT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
AND PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHIRLEY
WEBER AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JORDAN CUNNINGHAM. THERE
WAS WHERE PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
SOME MEMBERS COOLEY PATTERSON
AND SALAS TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIA SPEAK ON IN GERMANY
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
ENJOYABLE SIXTY TWO WAY THE
FONG NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TO HEAR SB TWO NINETY
FIVE MCGUIRE ON WEDNESDAY.
AUGUST TWENTY EIGHT PENNY RE
REFER ALL FROM THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE RETURN ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY COOLEY TO THE SENATE FOR
FURTHER ACTION. THE CLERK WILL
NOTE. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR IS PLEASE REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS IN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE
SB ONE SEVENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN
DODD ITEM ONE THIRTY FOUR EST
BEFORE THIRTY NINE I'M BURKE
ITEM ONE THIRTY SEVEN SB FIVE
SIXTY MCGUIRE AND ITEM ONE
FORTY ONE SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX
CAMBIADO. THE CLERK WILL AGAIN
NO I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO WITHDRAW IT AB FIFTEEN
THIRTEEN HOLDEN. FROM IN ROMAN
AND RETURN THE BILL TO THE
SENATE. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. AND MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I'M RE
REFER IN THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN
AB THIRTEEN OH THREE O'DONNELL
TO THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE. AN
ITEM TWENTY AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
TWO PETRIE-NORRIS TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
. MEMBERS
WE HAVE SPECIAL GUEST WITH US
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE SOME ROOM
TO MS BAUER K. HAND SO SHE MAY.
INTRODUCE HER SPECIAL GAS MS
BARRICADE HAND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY IN
THE GALLERY I WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME AND INTRODUCE FAMILY
AND FRIENDS FOR THE NATALIE
GEORGIE SUNSHINE FOUNDATION.
THE FOUNDATION IS NAMED AFTER
NATALIE GEORGIE THIS IS HER IN
THE PICTURE. SHE WAS AN AMAZING
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD HIS LIFE WAS
CUT TRAGICALLY SHORT FROM AN
ALLERGIC REACTION FROM PEANUTS.
THE FOUNDATION GOT ITS NAME
FROM HER BEAUTIFUL SMILE WHICH
YOU CAN SEE HERE. SINCE THE
PASSING OF NATALIE THE
FOUNDATION HAS WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO STRENGTHEN LAWS
TO PROTECT THOSE WHO ALSO
SUFFER FROM DEADLY ALLERGIES.
INCLUDING NATALIE SISTER
DANIELLE. THEY WORKED
TIRELESSLY ON SB TWELVE SIXTY
SIXTY SIX WITH FORMER SENATOR
BOB HUFF. TO REQUIRE AT THE
PINS IN ALL QUE FOR TWELVE
SCHOOLS. THIS YEAR I HAD THE
HONOR OF WORKING WITH THE
FOUNDATION TO ENSURE THAT ALL
RESTAURANT WORKERS HAVE PROPER
KNOWLEDGE OF HANDLING FOODS
WITH ALLERGENS AND CROSS
CONTAMINATION PREVENTION. BUT
THEIR WORK IS NOT DONE AND I
LOOK FORWARDTO PARTNERING THEM
IN THE FUTURE TO CONTINUE TO
PROTECT ALL THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA THAT SUFFER FROM
THESE DEADLY ALLERGENS. I WANT
TO WELCOME MY CONSTITUENTS.
LEWIS IN JOANNE GEORGIE AND
THEIR CHILD DANIELLE. AND
EIGHTY EIGHT THEN HER CHILDREN
CONNOR TAYLOR IN RYAN'S ARE
CHAMBER TODAY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK IN MAKING CALIFORNIA
A BETTER PLACE. AND MR SALAS
YOU HAVE. GUESTS WITH US WHO
HAVE ARRIVED IN THE CHAMBER
MISTER SALAS YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING TODAY. USED TO
INTRODUCE THE CALIFORNIA FARM
WORKER FOUNDATION IS JOINING US
IN THE GALLERY TODAY MY
DISTRICT THE FOUNDATION
ORGANIZED IN THE LAST BY MEDIA
EVENTS IN OUR URBAN AND DELAY
NO PROVIDING VALUABLE
INFORMATION TO FAMILIES THEY
ALSO OFFER SERVICES SUCH AS
IMMIGRATION CLINICS WOMEN'S
SELF DEFENSE WORKSHOPS.
FINANCIAL WELLNESS WORKSHOPS
BUSINESS CLASSES HEALTH
EDUCATION CLASSES ENGLISH
LEARNING CLASSES AND MUCH MUCH
MORE AB MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING THEM TO THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. AND MR SALAS YOUR
AGAIN RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING GOLD STAR MOTHERS
AND THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS IN
HONOR OF GOLD STAR MOTHERS AND
FAMILIES THEY PROCLAIMED BY AC
OR SIXTY ONE ACR SIXTY ONE WILL
DESIGNATE SEPTEMBER TWENTY NINE
TWENTY NINETEEN AS GOLD STAR
MOTHERS AND FAMILIES THE
CALIFORNIA GOLD STAR MOTHERS OF
AMERICA WAS FOUNDED IN NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT AFTER WORLD WAR
ONE FOR MOTHERS WHO LOST THEIR
SONS AND DAUGHTERS WILL
SERVING. IN THE ARMED FORCES
NATIONALLY THIS DAY HAS BEEN
RECOGNIZED ON THE LAST SUNDAY
IN SEPTEMBER SINCE ITS FIRST
PROCLAMATION ON JUNE TWENTY
THIRD NINETEEN THIRTY SIX WITH
US TODAY ON THE FLOOR WE HAVE
GUESTS FROM OUR BIGGEST FULL
AMERICAN GOLD STAR MOTHERS
CHAPTER AS WELL AS THE KINGS
COUNTY AND FROM THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA GOLD STAR MOTHERS
CHAPTER. WITH US TODAY WE HAVE
CARE IN GALION OF THE AMERICAN
GOLD STAR MOTHERS BIG FULL
CHAPTER IN HER HUSBAND JOEL WE
HAVE ROSALIE FOR BACON OR
HUSBAND TRAVIS RUBY WE HAVE
JUST A MOTHER ROLANDO CORRAL
HERE STEVE ON CAROLINE FORTY
LEN LINDA AND HER HUSBAND
MANUAL FULL GAME JERRY BAILEY
KAREN MEREDITH PRESIDENT OF THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AMERICAN
GOLD STAR MOTHER DEPARTMENT
DIANNE LAYFIELD THE REFERENCE
TO THE GOLD STAR COMES FROM THE
CUSTOMER FAMILIES OF SERVICE
MEMBERS. HANGING A SERVICE FLAG
IN THE WINDOW OF THEIR HOMES
DISPLAYING A GOLD STAR IN HONOR
OF THEIR FALLEN LOVED ONES WE
MUST NOT ONLY HONOR THE SERVICE
MEMBERS WE HAVE LOST WITH THEIR
FAMILIES AND LOVED ONES AS WELL
WHO CONTINUE TO SERVE OUR
COUNTRY BY SUPPORTING FELLOW
VETERANS AND THEIR COMMUNITIES
ENCOURAGE YOU TO RECOGNIZE GOLD
STAR MOTHERS AND FAMILIES IN
YOUR OWN COMMUNITIES FOR THE
SACRIFICES THEY MADE AND FOR
THE COMMITMENT TO THEIR
SERVICE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON ACR SIXTY ONE WHEN
WE VOTE ON IT LATER TODAY
MEMBERS THANK YOU PLEASE
RECOGNIZE. EACH OF GOLD STAR
FAMILIES AS THEY ARE UP TO DATE
WITH
. AND MEMBERS. I WOULD LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON FROM THE REAR THE
CHAMBER FROM MY DESK MISTER
PATTERSON. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. IT IS A
ABSOLUTE DELIGHT IN A GREAT
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE A VERY
TALENTED YOUNG MAN AND RESIDENT
OF THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT
MARK CASTRO. AT NINETEEN YEARS
OLD MARK IS AN INTERNATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED AMATEUR BOXER HIS
STORY IS ONE OF THE GREAT
SUCCESS. LISTEN TO THIS WITH A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY WINS SEVEN
LOSSES AN AMATEUR BOUNCE MARK
IS JUST GETTING STARTED BUT
HE'S ALREADY ACCOMPLISHED THIS
TO TIME AMMETER WORLD CHAMPION.
TWO TIME NATIONAL JUNIOR
OLYMPICS CHAMPION THREE TIME
NATIONAL SILVER GLOVES CHAMPION
THREE TIME BRING SIDE WORLD
CHAMPION SIXTEEN TIME NATIONAL
CHAMPION. YEAH WE'RE HEARING
THE CHEERS ON THE SIDELINE IT'S
JUST GETTING BETTER FOLKS MARK
STARTED BOXING AT THE AGE OF
FOUR. AND HE WAS UNDER THE
WATCHFUL CARING AND
PROFESSIONAL. OF HIS DAD TONY
TONY IS HERE WITH US HE JOINS
US IN THE GALLERY RIGHT UP HERE
THANK YOU DAD. ALSO. ALSO IS
MARK KNOWS YOU YOU YOU CAN'T DO
ALL OF THIS WITHOUT CLOSE
FRIENDS AND SUPPORTERS MARTIN
CHAVEZ IS HERE HE'S A CLOSE
FRIEND ALEX TAURUS IS HERE A
CLOSE FRIEND AND ONE OF HIS
GREAT SPONSORS ADAM BEYONCE'S
HERE WE WANT TO THANK THEM AS
WELL FOR HELPING MARK BECOME
ALL. THAT HE HAS BEEN ABLE TO
ACHIEVE. AT FIFTEEN YEARS OLD
MARK WAS SPARRING WITH
PROFESSIONAL BOXERS. AND
ACTUALLY BEAT THE FUEL. LAST
YEAR HE WON HIS FIRST MAN'S USA
NATIONAL LEAGUE TITLE. BUT IT'S
NOT JUST A TALENTED BOXERHE'S
ALSO A DEDICATED STUDENT HE
GRADUATED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AS THE VALEDICTORIAN OF
SUNNYSIDE HIGH SCHOOL. MARK IS
A FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
STUDENT HE IS A PROUD FRESNO
STATE BULLDOGS. HE JOINS ME IN
SUGGESTING THAT USC MEMBERS ON
THE FLOOR NEED TO PREPARE FOR
THE BULLDOGS NEXT SATURDAY.
BECAUSE WE'RE COMING AT YOU.
THIS. THIS FALL THIS IS. THIS
FALL MARK WILL COMPETE IN THE
OLYMPICS QUALIFIER FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY TOKYO OLYMPIC
GAMES HERE IS HIS DREAM AND
HERE'S WHY HE'S HERE SO WE CAN
RECOGNIZE HIM AND CHEER HIM ON
IN SEEING TO IT THAT HE
REALIZES THIS DREAM HIS DREAM.
IS TO WIN AN OLYMPIC GOLD MEDAL.
REPRESENT HIS COMMUNITY. HIS
STATE. AND HIS NATION. AS THE
SON OF IMMIGRANTS IN WINNING IN
A ROW OLYMPIC GOLD MEDAL
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING MARK HERE TODAY AND
CHEERING HIM ON TO HIS GOAL
.
MEMBERS OF I COULD HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION PLEASE. WE WILL NOW
BE MOVING TO THE SCIENCE
FELLOWS CEREMONY MR COOLEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FROM MY DESK IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER MEMBERS.
MR COOLEY. COLLEAGUES LAWS ARE
IDEAS AND A CHOIR OF FOLLOWING.
AND IN OUR WORK REQUIRING THAT
FOLLOWING DEPENDS UPON HAVING
GOOD IDEAS IDEAS THAT STAND THE
TEST OF. STRINGENT
CONSIDERATION. AND TO THIS END
WE ENJOY IN THE LEGISLATURE.
THE PARTICIPATION. OF
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY THESE ARE OUR PH DIS.
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY PLAYS A KEY
ROLE IN OUR STATE'S ECONOMY.
AND INTERNATIONAL LEADERSHIP AS
A STATE AN INCREASING ROLE IN
THE LEGISLATION WE CONSIDER ON
THIS FLOOR. THANKS TO THE CCSD
SCIENCE FELLOWS PROGRAM WE'RE
ABLE ENJOY THE BENEFIT. OF
SEVERAL OF SAN INDIVIDUALS WHO
SHARE THEIR SPECIAL KNOWLEDGE
AND MAKE VALUABLE CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE PUBLIC POLICY WE SHAPE
HERE. COLLEAGUES I AM PLEASED
TODAY TO RECOGNIZE. OUR. FOUR
OF OUR FIVE CST SCIENCE BELLOWS
FOR THE CURRENT YEAR I ASKED
HER TO READ THE NAMES OF THESE
SITES FELT. DR JERED FERGUSON
SERVE IN THE ASSEMBLY WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SUPPORTER GARCIA AND GALLAGHER
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR. HE HOLDS
A PHD IN APPLIED PHYSICS FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN ANN
ARBOR ANY GRADUATE CERTIFICATE
IN SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY AND
PUBLIC POLICY FROM MICHIGAN
ZERO FOUR SCHOOL OF PUBLIC
POLICY. DR LANDING CLIENT
SERVER THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
AND GALLAGHER CHAIRED BY
. DR
LANDING FINE SIR TO THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE AND
GALLAGHER CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
HE RECEIVED HIS PHD IN
NEUROSCIENCE IS IT UC SAN DIEGO
AND DOLE BACHELOR'S DEGREES IN
BIOLOGY AND PSYCHOLOGY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY. OF NORTH CAROLINA
AT CHAPEL HILL
. DOCTOR
ARISTOCRATIC SERVED IN THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WOULD AND
MAYES ARE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR.
SHE HOLDS A PHD IN
ENDOCRINOLOGY AND REPRODUCTIVE
PHYSIOLOGY FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF WISCONSIN MADISON AND A BA
IN NEUROSCIENCE FROM JUNE
UNIVERSITY IN MADISON NEW
JERSEY
. OKAY DOCTOR ADDITION TO
YOUR MATURITY SERVE ANY
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN FLOOR. OR CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR HEELS A PHD. MR
COOLEY. DR PERSONNEL VENT GAYS
SERVING THE ASSEMBLY
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS QUIRK AND MELENDEZ A
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR SHIELD A
PHD IN BIOINFORMATICS AND
COMPUTATIONAL BIOLOGY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF MINNESOTA AND SHE
RECEIVED DEGREES IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE FROM THE COLORADO
SCHOOL OF MINES AND FOOD
MICROBIOLOGY FROM CORNELL
UNIVERSITY. MEMBERS LET'S GIVE
OUR SCIENCE FELLOWS A BIG ROUND
OF APPLAUSE
. MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
CONCURRENCE ITEMS. FILE ITEMS
ONE THROUGH THREE. PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM FOR IS AB TEN
EIGHTEEN BY MR FRAZIER. CLOCK
RATE ASSEMBLY BILL TEN EIGHTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
ACCOLADE A REAL ESTATE
APPRAISAL THIS FRAZIER MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TEN EIGHTEEN
COMES BACK FOR CONCURRENCE FROM
THE SENATE WITH ONLY TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
OVER THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF.
IT IS OUT OF IT ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO SARAJEVO. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE CEREMONY. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM FIVE A. B. FOR
THIRTEEN CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR THIRTEEN BY SOME
REMEMBER JONES SAWYER AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO YOU
MISTER JONES SAWYER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AB FOUR ONE THREE
WHICH CHANGES REFERENCES OF AT
RISK TAP PROMISE IN THE
EDUCATION AND PENAL CODES IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENT SIMPLY
ADDICT A CO AUTHOR INCLUDED
CHAPTER IN OUT. LANGUAGE FOR
FAR TOO LONG TO STIGMATIZE
LABEL THAT RACE HAS BEEN USED
TO DESCRIBE YOUTH LIVING A
DIFFICULT SITUATION AND FOCUSED
ON YOUR LIKELIHOOD BECOMING
JUST ANOTHER STATISTIC THIS IS
A PERCEPTION ISSUE. BY USING
THIS TERM WE ARE CREATING
EXPECTATIONS OF FAILURE FOR OUR
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS AND
STIFLING OPPORTUNITIES THIS
BIAS MINE SAID AS PRESIDENT
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT POOR
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF COLOR.
THE STUDENTS ARE MORE THAN
THEIR SITUATION AND THEY NEED
TO BE TREATED AS SUCH INDEED
THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE
START WITH HOW WE TREAT OUR
YOUTH AND BEING MORE
INTENTIONAL WITH OUR LANGUAGE
BY TRANSITIONING FROM MAC WRIST
I PROMISE CALIFORNIA SETS A
NATIONWIDE PRECEDENT. FOR
RECOGNIZING THE INHERENT
POTENTIAL EVERY CHILD TO
SUCCEED THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
PART BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS MEMBERS.
ARE WORDS DO MATTER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
THEY RESTAURANTS WHERE SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLARK WELL
OVER THE ROLE ALL MEMBER
SERVICE OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
FOR DESSERT ABOUT. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIE BUT I FIFTY FIVE
KNOWS THREE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM SIX
IS AB SEVEN OH SEVEN BY MISTER
KALRA. KERKORIAN ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN OH SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER
KALRA ANOTHER SNACK LATER
PUBLIC CONTRACTS MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB SEVEN OH SEVENS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS AB SEVEN OH SEVEN
UPDATE THE FORMAL BIDDING
PROCESS AND FORCE ACCOUNT
THRESHOLDS FOR CONTRACTING WITH
THE CENTER VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT. SENATE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN UP TO AB SEVEN OH SEVEN
FURTHER CLARIFY THE TYPES OF
EXEMPTIONS THE DISTRICT CAN USE
CONDUCT INFORMAL CONTRACTING
AND REQUIRES ALL CONTRACTING
DECISIONS WE MADE A PUBLIC
MEETING. THE MANAGER MOVED ALL
OPPOSITION THE BILL WHICH
ULTIMATELY PASS THE SENATE ON
UNANIMOUS FORTY TWO ZERO VOTERS
AT THE ASPEN AYE. THANK YOU
MISTER KALRA SEE NO DISCUSSION
OF A CLERK LIBERAL. VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM SEVEN IS AB SEVENTEEN
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN BY SOME MEMBERS SALAS
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
ELECTIONS MISTER CELIS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
PERCENT BEFORE YOU ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN ALSO KNOWN AS A
VOTER PROTECTION ACT THIS ACT
IS AIMED AT PROTECTING BALLOT
INTEGRITY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS WAR TECHNICAL IN
NATURE RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
THANK YOU. THEY WERE SALAS SEE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. CARPOOL
OF THE ROLE. NUMBER SERVICE ARE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT
OF THE. ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL
TIVER ICT FIVE KNOWS ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM EIGHT IS AB THREE
OH NINE COOKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE OH NINE BY SOME MEMBER
RANGE ON AN ACCOLADE TO
VEHICLES THIS MAIENSCHEIN THANK
YOU MISTER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB THREE OH
NINE IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
THIS BILL PERMITS HISTORICAL
SOCIETIES IN MUSEUMS TO DISPLAY
POLICE VEHICLES MEMBERS FOR
TECHNICAL AND CLARA FIND IN
NATURE. AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I ABOUT. THANK YOU
MISS MAIENSCHEIN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OVER THE ROLE. SERVICE OUT OF
THEM ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS HER DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSE YOUR
ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM
NINE IS AB FOR NINETEEN. CLOCK
RATE. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
NINETEEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE AN ACCOLADE FOOD
AGRICULTURE MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION OR FOR. DOCTOR
EGGMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FOR
NINETEEN IS IT AGRICULTURE
OMNIBUS BILL HAVING TO DO WITH
THE STANDARDIZATION OF OUR
FRUITS NUTS AND VEGETABLES I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT
OF A CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL
TELL YOU THAT I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FIVE ONE IN TEN
AB FIVE OH FOUR CLERK WILL
READ. SOME PEOPLE FIVE OH FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN
ACCOLADE TO ELECTIONS. MR
BERMAN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES AB FIVE OH FOUR
CLARIFIES VOTER RESIDENCY
CONFIRMATION PROCEDURES THAT
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS MUST
FOLLOW IN STORES THAT STATE
LAWS CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS. THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ENSURE THAT A FAVOR
BY THE FOUR DOUBLE NOTICE IS
SENT BY THE ELECTION OFFICIAL
WHENEVER A VOTERS REGISTRATION
IS MADE AN ACTIVE AS REQUIRED
BY FEDERAL LAW AND UPDATES THE
TEXT OF ADDRESS CONFIRMATION
NOTICES. THAT ARE SENT TO
VOTERS SO THAT THOSE NOTICES
MORE ACCURATELY DESCRIBE THE
VOTERS REGISTRATION STATUS AB
FIVE OH FOUR SPONSORED BY THE
SECTOR STATE OUT EXPEDIA AND IS%
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA'S
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS AND
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS. IN
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AMONG OTHERS IT IS NO
OPPOSITION AND IS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SO I'M
NOT SURE WHY I'VE SPOKEN THIS
LONG BUT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON CAN CURRENTS
AND SENATE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU MISTER BERMAN SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLICK
LIBERAL MEMBERS. WE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS BETTER IS OUT
OF THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SEVENTY NO
ZERO. SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM ELEVEN.
AB FIVE FIVE EIGHT. COVERAGE
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIVE EIGHT
BY SOME MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
AND OTHERS ARE LIKELY TO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS. THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB FIVE FIVE EIGHT IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE MINOR AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKEN OUT WHICH ARE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I'VE
IT. THANK YOU IS PETRIE-NORRIS
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
WHAT I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM TWELVE. AB SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE FIVE MISTER CHAO
CLICK AWAY. SOMEPEOPLE SEVEN
SOME FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHILD ACCOLADE HEALING ARTS
THIS CHAP THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB SEVEN SEVEN FIVE IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ESTABLISH CERTAIN
DEFINITIONS AND REVISE THE
SCHOOL APPROVAL TIMELINE TO
MAKE THEM WORKABLE FOR THE C. A
M. T. C. TO IMPLEMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINGS CHAO SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS OTHERS
ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
REPRESENTATIVE OF. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY NINE OH ZERO CENTER MA'AM
AND SIR CONCURRED IN FILE ITEMS
THIRTEEN THROUGH SIXTEEN PASS
RETAIN OR FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
AB FIFTEEN FOR CORPORATE SOME
PEOPLE FIFTEEN OH FOUR BY SOME
MEMBER MEDINA ACCOLADE
COMMUNICABLE WHICH IS MISTER
MEDINA THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS A. B. FIFTEEN OH
FOUR IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE IN
TECHNICAL IN NATURE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA SAYING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THEM. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE. CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIE THAT I FIFTY
THREE KNOWS NINE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN. IS AB
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN BY MS FRIEDMAN.
THE CLERK. WELL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
ACTUALLY IN THE LAND USE THIS
FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AMENDMENTS MADE
TO AB FIFTEEN FIFTEEN THE
SENATE WERE TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING IN NATURE AB FIFTEEN
FIFTEEN ASSISTS THE COMMUNITY
PLAN UPDATE PROCESS PROVIDES
CLARITY TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
RESIDENTS AND DEVELOPERS AND
HOW TO IMPLEMENT AN UPDATED
COMMUNITY PLAN SHOULD ITS
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENT BE
CLARIFIED IN THE CHALLENGED IN
COURT. AB FIFTEEN FIFTEEN IS
SPONSORED BY LA MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI THE BILL IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I REQUEST WE ARE
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MS FREEMAN SAYING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM QUIRK
LIBERAL. RESERVE OUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO
GO. CLERK. WELL CLOSER ROLL
TIDE BUT I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEMS NINETEEN AND
TWENTY. HAS TO RETAIN. ON
RECONSIDERATION ITEMS TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX AND TWENTY
SEVEN ARE TO BE CONTINUED. THAT
MOVES US TO THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE. FILE ITEMS TWENTY
EIGHT. THROUGH THIRTY FOUR PASS
AND RETAIN. WE ARE FILE ITEM
THIRTY FIVE H. R. EIGHT BY MR
VOEPEL CLERK WILL READ HOUSE
RESOLUTION EIGHT BY SOME MEMBER
VOEPEL RELATIVE TO GERMAN
AMERICAN HERE TO STAY AND MARK.
THIS VOEPEL MRS SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. SEPTEMBER OCTOBER. AND
SIDING WITH OKTOBERFEST WILL BE
GERMAN AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH.
THEN I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT
TO ALL MY BROTHERS AND SISTERS
ON THE FLOOR HERE. THAT GERMANS
STARTED COMING TO AMERICA. FROM
JAMES TOWN ON AND HAVE
CONTRIBUTED GREATLY. TO THE
COUNTRY. TODAY OVER FORTY TWO
POINT EIGHT MILLION GERMANS ARE
IN AMERICA. AND SIX MILLION IN
CALIFORNIA. NOW WHAT I FIND
INTERESTING ABOUT THIS AND ALSO
ANY OTHER IN MAY GE IMMIGRANT
GROUP. IS. PEOPLE SAY THAT
AMERICA IS A MELTING POT. I
BELIEVE. MY OPINION THAT
AMERICA IS LIKE A SALAD A
BEAUTIFUL SALAD MADE UP OF ALL
SORTS OF DIFFERENT WONDERFUL
THINGS. AND IF THERE IS A
MELTING POT ITS DNA. AND OUR
WHOLE. POPULATION IS MADE UP OF
INCREDIBLE AMOUNTS OF DIFFERENT
DNA FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD.
THERE IS NO OTHER NATION IN THE
WORLD THAT REPRESENTS THE WORLD
THEN US. SO. WITH THAT IN MIND
14% OF AMERICAN DNA IS GERMAN.
AND. STE AS FAR AS GUMP WOULD
SAY SO MUCH FOR THAT. SO THIS
MONTH WILL BE GERMAN AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH ANDI'M PROUD TO
RECOGNIZE THE GERMAN CONSULATE
AND- THE DNA THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER VOEPEL MS BURNER
**** BATH. YEAH I KOLLEGEN AND
LEAVE A CLICK AND THEN CLICKING
IN ALL IS STAY AWAY TO MASUDI
DEUTSCHE AMERICANA SHOULD TODD
THE CLUB WAS SERVICE TICKET
CLEAR BUT I CAN IS TO DO MUCH
AMERICA SHOULD TARGET IN TODD
SOME MONEY CAN APPLY TO DO TO
WATCH ON THE AMERICANA CHART.
STOCKS BUSH OF TOM THE VISIT OF
MINE CAN THEN THE WATCH ON THE
BOARD ISN'T IT GLOBAL THAN
FIGHTING TO BE VERY YES EL
FATHER THE ESSENCE OF THE STATE
THAT'S REALLY INTO NOT
KNOWLEDGE AS OFTEN I'LL BITE
SESSION ON THE LINDA WAS ON ITS
MISSION CALIFORNIAN ONDANSETRON
RECURSOS FISH BECAUSE- SO THAT
WAS A. LONG WAY TO SAY HAPPY
GERMAN AMERICAN DAY. THERE HAD
TO BE MORE TO IT THAN THAT I
THINK. SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION. MR VOEPEL
YOU MAY CLOSE ON THE RESOLUTION
WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS. YES
PLEASE FOR CO AUTHORS AND. THAT
WAS A BEAUTIFUL RENDITION OF
DEUTSCHE NOW I WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND ALL MEMBERS. YOU ALL
SPEAK FLUENT GERMAN. BUD VISOR.
MILA OLD. POPS SCHLITZ AND. ALL
DAHLE OH NO NO NO DON'T BE
THINKING THAT. ADOLPH COORS WE
ALL SPEAK GERMAN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU
MISTER PATEL THE AUTHOR IS
REQUESTING CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON H. R. AIDS. CLICK
WELL. CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE
SEVENTY CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
THIRTY SIX ACR ONE FIFTEEN.
QUICKLY. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE
KAMLAGER-DOVE RELATIVE TO
GRANULATED BUSINESS. MS
KAMLAGER-DOVE IF YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS I
AM HERE TO PRESENT ACR ONE
FIFTEEN WHICH URGES THE SIX
BANKS THAT HAVE OPENED DEMAND
ACCOUNTS WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO RECONSIDER THEIR
LENDING PRACTICES AND STOP
LENDING TO GUN MANUFACTURERS.
THERE IS POWER IN LEVERAGING
MONEY SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY AND
THE GROWING FURY AROUND THE GUN
VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC IN AMERICA.
AND BANKS HAVE POWER. THEY USE
THEIR POWER TO DIVEST FROM
SOUTH AFRICA IN OPPOSITION TO
APARTHEID MANY NO LONGER
FINANCE PRIVATE PRISONS AND
THEY WILLINGLY DECLINE TO LYNN
TO ROGUE NATIONS WITH ON
DEMOCRATIC INTENTIONS LET'S ASK
THEM TO USE THEIR POWER TO HELP
STOP MORE INNOCENCE FROM
BECOMING VICTIMS OF MASS
SHOOTINGS. PUBLIC DISCOURSE
REGARDING GUN VIOLENCE OFTEN
LOOKS TO THE DEMAND FACTOR THIS
RESOLUTION AIMS TO SHIFT THAT
DISCOURSE INSTEAD TO THE SUPPLY
FACTOR. THE SUPPLY OF GUNS
CURRENTLY EXCEEDS THE DEMAND
14% OF CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS OWN
GUNS 10% OF THOSE GUN OWNERS
GUN OWNERS OWN OVER TEN GUNS.
MENTAL ILLNESS VIDEO GAMES AND
THE INTERNET ARE ALL COMMONLY
CITED AS THE SOURCE OF GUN
VIOLENCE HOWEVER OUR NEIGHBOR
TO THE NORTH CAñADA HAS ALL OF
THESE THINGS BUT FAR LESS GUN
VIOLENCE THE DIFFERENCE THEY
HAVE FEWER GUNS. OTHER
INDUSTRIES HAVE TAKEN A STAND
AGAINST GUN MANUFACTURERS DELTA
AIRLINES AND HURTS BROKE WITH
THE NRA FOLLOWING THE PARK LAND
SHOOTING AND DICK'S SPORTING
GUNS MAY DICK'S SPORTING GOODS
MADE GUNS HARDER TO BUY.
CERTAIN BANKS HAVE ALREADY
TAKEN SIMILAR ACTION TO THAT
WHICH IS CALLED FOR AN ACR ONE
FIFTEEN FOR INSTANCE CITY BANK
BAND RETAILERS THAT USE THE
BANK FROM OFFERING BUMP STOPS.
AND SELLING GUNS TO UNDERAGE
CUSTOMERS OR THOSE WHO HAVE NOT
PASSED BACKGROUND CHECKS BANK
OF AMERICA THEN CAME OUT WITH
ITS OWN SET OF RESTRICTIONS
ENDING LOANS TO COMPANIES THAT
MANUFACTURE ADULT STYLE WEAPONS
USED FOR NON MILITARY PURPOSES.
MANY BANKS ARGUE THAT DEMANDING
SUCH DIVESTMENT ACTION IS
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED AND THAT
BANKS SHOULD BE FREE FROM
POLITICAL PRESSURE. BUT
PROTECTING THE LIVES OF
AMERICANS SHOULD BE ABOUT
BIPARTISAN IF NOT ENTIRELY A
NON POLITICAL ISSUE. THIS
RESOLUTIONDOES NOT DEMAND THAT
GUN MANUFACTURERS HOPE
PRODUCTION IT DOES NOT ASK
CIVILIANS TO STOP PURCHASING
GUNS THIS IS NOT A SECOND
AMENDMENT BILL. THIS IS NOT A
DIVESTMENT BILL. THIS
RESOLUTION ENCOURAGES THOSE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS WITH
OPEN DEMAND ACCOUNTS WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
REEVALUATE THEIR LENDING
PRACTICES PARTICULARLY AS THEY
APPLIED TO GUN MANUFACTURERS.
IT ASKS FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
TO DO AS WE ALL SHOULD WHICH IS
TO BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE PART
WE PLAY IN A CONTINUALLY
GROWING NATIONAL PROBLEM AND TO
CHANGE OUR BEHAVIOR TO REFLECT
OUR VISION FOR A SAFER FUTURE.
OUR COUNTRY IS FACING A MULTI
PRONGED SICKNESS. AND WE NEED
MULTI STRATEGY SOLUTIONS. WE
MUST ALL TAKE A LOOK AT OUR
HABITS OUR PRACTICES AND OUR
EFFORTS TO SEE HOW WE SHARE A
PART OF THE COLLECTIVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE GUN
VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC INCLUDING OUR
BANKS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THERE WAS
KAMLAGER-DOVE MS MELENDEZ YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS BILL IS
EXTORTION THIS BILL. SAYS THAT
IT ONCE AGAIN MANUFACTURES A
RETAILER TO ADOPT LENDING
PRACTICES THAT NEAR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA'S VALUES YET NO
DEFINITION IS GIVEN OF THAT WE
DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
IT SITE CITY BANK. THAT SERVED
AS AN EXAMPLE ARE FOR GUN
POLICIES BY ADOPTING A POLICY
PROHIBITING THE SALES OF
FIREARMS BY ITS BUSINESS
CUSTOMERS TO INDIVIDUALS
YOUNGER THAN TWENTY ONE YEARS
OLD THERE ARE A LOT OF STATES
WHO ALLOW PEOPLE WHO ARE
YOUNGER THAN TWENTY ONE TO
PURCHASE. A RIFLE. BUT
CALIFORNIA IS NOW GOING TO TRY
TO IMPOSE ITS GUN CONTROL
MEASURES ON THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY BY THREATENING THE
BANKS BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THIS
IS THIS IS A THREAT. NO MATTER
HOW MANY TIMES THE AUTHOR TELLS
YOU THIS BILL DOESN'T FORCE
THEM TO DO ANYTHING IF YOU READ
THE RESOLUTION IT IS PRETTY
CLEAR WHAT THE MESSAGES THAT
LISTED THERE HOW MUCH MONEY. IS
INVESTED WITH THEIR HELP WITH
THESE BANKS FOR CAL STARS IN
CALPERS. IT'S A LOT OF MONEY.
AND THE VEILED THREAT OR THINLY
VEILED THREAT FRANKLY IS IF YOU
DON'T DO WHAT WE WANT YOU TO DO
REGARDING GUN RIGHTS THEN YOU
WON'T GET OUR BUSINESS AND YOU
WILL LOSE MONEY SO WE WANT YOU
GOT MANY FACTORS AGAIN
RETAILERS TO IMPOSE. OUR WILL
ON THE REST OF THE COUNTRY. AND
I WILL REMIND YOU THAT ALTHOUGH
THERE IS ONE MENTION IN THIS
RESOLUTION. ABOUT EXEMPTING
WEAPONS FOR MILITARY USE THERE
IS NO MENTION IN HERE OF
WEAPONS THAT ARE USED FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. SO YOU TELL ME
THIS IF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WANTS TO PUSH ALL OF THESE
BANKS BIG BANK SIX MAJOR BANKS
WANT TO PUSH THESE BANKS
NATIONWIDE TO NOT PROVIDE
FINANCIAL SERVICES TOO MANY
FACTORS AND RETAILERS OF
FIREARMS. THEN WHO WHO WILL
MAKE THEM WHERE WILL LAW
ENFORCEMENT GET THE ONE TOOL
THAT THEY NEED. TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES OR YOU. WHERE WILL
THEY GET THEM. BECAUSE MY
COUNTY RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT THEY
PURCHASE THEIR OWN WEAPONS. AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THAT DO
THE SAME. SO IF YOU MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO OBTAIN
THESE FAR ARMS WHAT EXACTLY ARE
THEY SUPPOSED TO DO AND I ASKED
THIS QUESTION IN COMMITTEE WHEN
THIS BILL WAS HEARD. IF YOU
DON'T MIND. I ASK THIS QUESTION
IN COMMITTEE WHEN THIS BILL WAS
HEARD IS THE GOAL TO PUT GUN
MANUFACTURERS AND RETAILERS OUT
OF BUSINESS OR TO PUT THEM IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE
A FINANCIAL INSTITUTION WITH
WHICH TO DO BUSINESS AND THE
ANSWER WAS THAT'S ONE. OF THE
GOALS. SAID THAT IS THE GOAL OF
THIS IN CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE A
PRETTY BIG STICK WITH FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE IN THIS STATE.
WITH A BIG ECONOMY. BUT IT IS
NOT THE GOVERNMENT'S JOB TO
IMPOSE ITS IDEALS ON A PRIVATE
INSTITUTION. THAT IS IN OUR JOB
IF WHAT'S NEXT SO YOU'RE GOING
TO SAY WELL WE DON'T WANT BANKS
DOING BUSINESS WITH SODA
MANUFACTURERS WE DON'T WANT YOU
DOING BUSINESS WITH OIL
MANUFACTURERS ARE ORDERED
FIRST. FUEL. FEEL COMPANIES
WHAT LIKE HOW FAR DO WE GO HERE.
THIS IS NOT THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE'S JOB. TO DECIDE TO
PUSH THE REST OF THE COUNTRY
AND PRIVATE BUSINESSES TO
IMPOSE THE GUN CONTROL MEASURES
THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY IF YOU
WANT TO DO THAT. YOU IF THAT'S
THE GOAL THAT YOU TALK TO
LEGISLATORS IN THESE OTHER
STATES AND HAVE THEM PASSED
LEGISLATION LIKE CALIFORNIA HAS.
I URGING ABOUT. THE THING IS
WELL AS MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE RESOLUTION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS ACR FIFTEEN AND
THANK THE AUTHOR FROM LOS
ANGELES FOR ONE STEPPING UP TO
THE PLATE THINKING OUT OF THE
BOX AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM LAKE
ELSINORE IS ARTICULATED HER
POINT ABOUT GOALS AND THE ROLE
IN THE JOB AND RESPONSIBILITY
OF THIS LEGISLATURE WELL I
THINK THE GOAL RESPONSIBILITY
OF THIS LEGISLATURE'S VERY
THING WE CAN SAVE LIVES. IF YOU
REPRESENT A DISTRICT OR JUST
TURN A NEWS OR LISTEN TO THE
RADIO PEOPLE ARE DYING EACH AND
EVERY DAY THEY'RE DYING NOT
BECAUSE SOMEONE STABBING THEM
THEY'RE DYING BECAUSE WE HAVE
GUNS OF MASS DESTRUCTION
THEY'RE DYING AND IN PUBLIC
PLACES OUR SCHOOLS ARE NOT SAFE
WE HEAR THAT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN GOING TO CONCERTS ARE NOT
SAFE WE'VE HEARD THAT TIME AND
TIME AGAIN. WHOSE
RESPONSIBILITY IS IT TO SAVE
THE LIVES OF EVERYTHING THAT WE
CAN TO SAVE THE LIVES OF THE
BABIES THAT GO TO OUR SCHOOLS
AND HE CALIFORNIA WHO ARE NOT
FEELING SAFE THE CHILDREN THAT
HAVE NIGHTMARES THE CHILDREN
HAVE NIGHTMARES EACH AND EVERY
DAY BECAUSE THEY ARE AFRAID OF
WHAT COULD POSSIBLY TAKE PLACE.
IN THEIR SCHOOL IT IS OUR LET
IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY WE ARE
BROTHERS AND SISTERS KEEPER AND
I THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT WAY
FOR US TO GO AND SO MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR STRONG I
VOTE FOR. YOU SEE OUR FIFTEEN
ONE FIFTY. THANK YOU MISTER
GIBSON SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION ON THE RESOLUTION MS
KAMLAGER-DOVE YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES BOTH FROM LIKE
ELSINORE AND FROM LOS ANGELES
AND COMPTON FOR. TALKING ON
THIS ISSUE OFTENTIMES WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE WE
ARE LOOKING AT SOLUTIONS.
THROUGH THE PENAL CODE AND THIS
IS A NEW AND A DIFFERENT
RESPONSE WE ALL SHARE A
COLLECTIVE RESPONSIBILITY AND
QUITE FRANKLY A NUMBER OF BANKS
ARE PROBABLY SEEING A LOSS OF
CLIENTS AND CUSTOMERS BECAUSE
THEY TOO HAVE BEEN VICTIMS OF
GUN VIOLENCE. THIS IS ASKING
FOR EVERYONE. ALL ENTITIES.
THAT PLAY A ROLE IN THIS
EPIDEMIC TO PUT SOME SKIN IN
THE GAME. SO THAT MAYBE THE
NEXT TIME WE ADJOURN WE ARE NOT
A JOINING IN THE MEMORY OF A
SIX YEAR OLD. SHOT AND KILLED
AND A GARLIC FESTIVAL. BECAUSE
SHE WANTED TO ENJOY. A
COMMUNITY DAY WITH HER FAMILY.
THIS IS ABOUT PUTTING A
DIFFERENT KIND OF SKIN IN THE
GAME. BECAUSE IT IS THIS TIME
IT IS TIME THAT WE COME UP WITH
THE NEW SOLUTIONS TO THIS
PROBLEM. I WOULD HATE FOR US TO
SEE THE DAY WHEN EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF US IN THIS CHAMBER
ADJOURNS IN THE MEMORY OF
SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN KILLED
FROM GUN VIOLENCE I HAVE HAD MY
SHARE OF IT. I AM ASSUMING THAT
MANY OTHERS HAVE TO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION AC ARE
ONE ONE FIVE. THERE WAS
KAMLAGER-DOVE WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE AC ARE. YES
THERE IS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE. AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. ADDING ON TO A SHARE
ONE FIFTEEN. CO AUTHORS. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLE THERE
ARE FORTY EIGHT CO AUTHORS
ADDED THERE IS OPPOSITION TO
THE RESOLUTION WE WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON THIS A SAY
ARE A C. R. THIS IS A ROLL CALL
OF. HER CLUB IN THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF OUR DESIRE TO VOTE
. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FORTY NINE NEWS SEVENTEEN THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM THIRTY
SEVEN A C. R. EIGHTY SEVEN.
CLICK AWAY ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY SEVEN BY SOME
REMEMBER QUIRK SILVA RELATIVE
TO CIVIC EDUCATION IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS MISS QUIRK SILVA. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
THE FOUNDATION OF DEMOCRACY
STARTS WITH THE EDUCATION OF
OUR CHILDREN. IT IS SAID THAT
WE LEARN FIRST WHEN WE ARE
TAUGHT AND THEN AGAIN WHEN WE
TEACH WHAT WE KNOW TO OTHERS.
IT IS THE CIVIC MISSION OF OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO PREPARE ALL
YOU YOUNG PEOPLE TO BE INFORMED
RESPONSIBLE AND ACTIVELY
ENGAGED IN CIVIC LIFE. ACR
EIGHTY SEVEN COMMEMORATES THE
CORNERSTONE ROLE PUBLIC SCHOOLS
PLAY IN SUSTAINING AND
PRESERVING DEMOCRACY THAT WE
PLEDGE TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS
AS THEY ARE PLEDGE TO BUILDING
A BETTER SOCIETY FOR ALL TO
LIVE IN. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND THAT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MS QUIRK SILVA MISTER
KILEY HERE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I A REPORT
BY THE CALIFORNIA TASK FORCE ON
K. TWELVE CIVIC LEARNING
HIGHLIGHTS A NUMBER OF
CONCERNING FRIENDS INCLUDING
THE UNITED STATES RANKS A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE. IN
VOTER PARTICIPATION IN THE
WORLD JUST 13% OF HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS IN CALIFORNIA SHOW A
SOLID UNDERSTANDING OF U. S.
HISTORY LESS THAN HALF OF OUR
SENIORS FEEL A RESPONSIBILITY
TO BE ACTIVELY INVOLVED. IN
STATE AND LOCAL ISSUES. NATION
WIDE SURVEYS CONSISTENTLY SHOW
THAT CIVIC KNOWLEDGE PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT AND TRUST IN
GOVERNMENT ARE AT AN ALL TIME
LOW. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY SEVEN IS A
POSITIVE STEP TOWARDS REVERSING
THESE TRENDS IN OUR STATE. THE
PROMISE OF CIVICS IS THAT A
CENTRAL PURPOSE OF EDUCATION IS
TO PREPARE FOR THE ROLE OF
CITIZENS. AND IN A TIME OF
GROWING POLITICAL DIVISION AND
WOMAN POLICY CHALLENGES THAT
ROLE IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER. A RENEWED FOCUS ON CIVIC
EDUCATION CAN UNLOCK THE
POTENTIAL OF EVERY YOUNG PERSON
TO BE AN ACTIVE PARTICIPANT IN
OUR SHARED PUBLIC LIFE.
ASSURING THAT THE NEXT
GENERATION IS EQUIPPED TO RENEW
AND REINVIGORATE OUR DEMOCRATIC
TRADITIONS. THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR LEARNING AND CIVIC
EDUCATION LAYS OUT A NUMBER OF
PROVEN PRACTICES FOR EFFECTIVE
CIVIC LEARNING. INCLUDING
PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY
INSTRUCTION IN GOVERNMENT
HISTORY LAW AND DEMOCRACY
INCORPORATING DISCUSSION OF
CURRENT LOCAL NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL ISSUES AND EVENTS
IN THE CLASSROOM. AND OFFERING
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES THE
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS TO GET INVOLVED IN
THEIR SCHOOLS AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES. RESEARCH
DEMONSTRATES THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO KNOW MORE ABOUT GOVERNMENT
ARE MORE LIKELY TO VOTE DISCUSS
POLITICS CONTACT THEIR
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS AND TAKE
PART IN OTHER CIVIC ACTIVITIES
AND THAT CIVIC INVOLVEMENT
EARLY IN LIFE CAN TRANSLATE
INTO GREATER PARTICIPATION. AS
AN ADULT. I ASPIRIN AYE VOTE ON
THIS RESOLUTION AND HOPE THAT
OUR LEGISLATURE ALONG WITH
GOVERNING BODIES AND CIVIC
ASSOCIATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. CAN HEAT ITS CALL FOR A
RENEWED COMMITMENT TO CIVICS
EDUCATION IN THE YEARS AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISS KILEY. SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
RESOLUTION IS QUIRK SILVA YOU
MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH. I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ROCKLAND FOR HIS ELBOW ELOQUENT
REMARKS AND ALSO ASK YOU TO
JOIN US ON THE CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
RESOLUTION ACR EIGHTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MS QUIRK SILVA THE
FIRST ROLL THE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL THEIR
SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE A. C.
R. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE FILE
ITEM THIRTY EIGHT. AC A EIGHT
BY MISTER LOWE CLOCK RATE.
ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOWERED OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE TO ELECTIONS. MR
LOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SAID
THIS IS A C. EIGHT THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT THAT
WOULD GO BEFORE THE ELECTORATE
TO LOWER THE VOTING AGE FROM
EIGHTEEN TO SEVENTEEN A NUMBER
OF YOU WERE GENEROUS ENOUGH
WITH YOUR SUPPORT IN PREVIOUS
ITERATIONS OF THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THIS ALSO CONTINUES
ON THE KEY ESSENCE OF THE WORK
FROM THE NUMBER OF SAN MATTEO
AND ALSO HIS FAMILY LEGACY AS
WELL TOO SO APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP THIS DOESN'T CHOI
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WITH OVER
THIRTY EIGHT CO AUTHORS. OUT
WITH ALL SUPPORT OF LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU MISTER LOWE
MISTER VOEPEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. WITH PARENTAL
PERMISSION. A SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLD CAN JOIN THE MILITARY.
FIGHT. AND DIE FOR THEIR
COUNTRY. SO I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BASED UPON THAT. BUT I'D ALSO
LIKE TO REMIND THIS BODY. OF
DâN BULLOCK UNITED STATES
MARINE CORPS. KILLED AT. AND
THE WHOLE COMBAT BASE NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE AGE FIFTEEN THE
YOUNGEST PERSON KILLED IN THE
VIETNAM WAR. WHAT I LED A
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD VOTE NO.
SIXTEEN NO. BUT SEVENTY WITH
PARENTAL PERMISSION TO JOIN THE
MILITARY YES I SUPPORT THANK
YOU MEMBERS. THANK YOU MITCHELL
HEALTH DOCTOR CHEN YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PUSHES YOUR TIME I
WANNA THANK YOU ALSO FOR BRING
UP THAT THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
TO THE FLOOR ALL I SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE AND I HUMBLY ASK FOR
YOUR- VOTE. THANK ELECTION. SEE
NOW ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. YEAH CLICK
OVER THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS
TAKES FIFTY FOUR
. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
FIFTY FOUR YES FOURTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE A. C. R.
TWENTY EIGHT. KERKORIAN. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TWENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
ANOTHER'S RELATIVE TO SICKLE
CELL DISEASE. MISTER GIBSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT ACR TWENTY
EIGHT WHICH WILL DECLARE
SEPTEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN A
CIRCLE SO DISEASE AWARENESS
MONTH SICKLE CELL DISEASE IS A
DEBILITATING BLOOD THIS ORDER
WITH NO KNOWN CURE THAT AFFECT
THIRTEEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS.
WHOSE AVERAGE LIFESPAN IS FORTY
THREE FROM TWO THOUSAND.
MEMBERS. THESE YOUR ATTENTION
MISTER GIBSON FROM TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR TO TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
THERE WERE FOUR HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SIX BABIES BORN WITH
SICKLE CELL DISEASE IN
CALIFORNIA AND FOR OTHER THESE
89% WERE AFRICAN AMERICANS THAT
IS WHY THIS YEAR'S BUDGET WE
ALLOCATE OR FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO CREATE SEVEN NEW
SICKLE CELL DISEASE SICKLE CELL
DISEASE CENTERS BUT WILL BE
LIFE CHANGING FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS WITH THIS CONDITION
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND THE FIRST WILL
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON AC
ARE. TWENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
MISS GIPSON SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON THE
ACR THE FIRST ROLL THE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. THEY RECESSES FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSER ALL. THERE ARE
SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED
THIS IS A FISCAL ITEM THEREFORE
WE WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE.
ON THE A. C. R. CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBER SERVICE
OUR TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. WE ARE FILE ITEM
FORTY. ACR NINETY EIGHT BY MS
WICKS CORKERY ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NINETY
EIGHT BY SOME MEMBER WORKS AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT MISS WICKS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDERS ARE LEADING
CAUSE OF DISABILITY IN THE
UNITED STATES AFFECTING ONE IN
FIVE ADULTS UNTREATED MENTAL
HEALTH ILLNESS CAN OFTEN LEAD
TO INCREASED HIGH SCHOOL
DROPOUT RATES HIGHER INCIDENCE
OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE. AND
INCREASED INTERACTION WITH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
UNFORTUNATELY FEWER THAN HALF
OF ADULTS WITH MENTAL SYSTEM
THIS DISORDERS HAVE ACCESS TO
TREATMENT FEWER THAN 10% OF
INDIVIDUALS AGES TWELVE AND
OLDER WITH A SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDER ABLE TO ACCESS
TREATMENT AND THREE AND FOUR
JAIL INMATES HAVE BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH BOTH A MENTAL
HEALTH ILLNESS AND THE
SUBSTANCE. ABUSE DISORDER. LACK
OF HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
ASSOCIATED OUT OF POCKET COSTS
AND DISPARATE TREATMENT BETWEEN
PHYSICAL MENTAL HEALTH. ALL ACT
AS BARRIERS TO ATTAINING MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DISORDER TREATMENT. WHILE
THERE ARE MENTAL HEALTH PARITY
LAWS OF THE STATE AND FEDERAL
LEVELS DESIGNED TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE GET THE SERVICES THEY
NEED. CRACKS THAT WE CANNOT
IGNORE STILL EXIST IN OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. ACR NINETY
EIGHT TAKES A STEP IN THIS
DIRECTION BY URGING THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE INSURANCE AND HEALTH
SERVICES AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO USE THE FULL. POWERS
OF THEIR OFFICES TO ADDRESS
THESE BARRIERS BY ENSURING THAT
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS. AND
HEALTH INSURANCE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPLY WITH FEDERAL
AND STATE LAWS ON MENTAL HEALTH
PARITY AND ADDICTION EQUITY.
THIS RESOLUTION HAS NO STATE
COST AND NO OPPOSITION I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS WICKS. MR
KANSEN CHU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
CHECK YOUR MAIL. MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF ACR NINETY EIGHT AND THANK
MY COLLEAGUES FROM OAKLAND AND
SAN DIEGO FOR INTRODUCING DOES
MEASURE YES ON MINE STUDY WHEN
I WAS WORKING ON MY AB EIGHT
THE SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN WELL A
WORD REALIZE DRIVE ONE IN FIVE
ADULTS HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER AND LESS THAN HALF
RECEIVE TREAT TREATMENT. BUT
FOR CHILDREN OVER 76% WHO HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS NEVER
RECEIVE TREATMENT AND THIS
NUMBER JUMPED TO OVER 86% FOR
CHILDREN LIVING IN PROPERTY OR
WHOSE PARENTS HAVE A LANGUAGE
BARRIER WE MUST DO BETTER AND
FIND SOLUTIONS TO BREAK DOWN
THE BARRIERS TO **** FOR
CHILDREN TO ALLOW FOR
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION. WE MUST TREAT
MENTAL HEALTH LIKE OR PHYSICAL
HEALTH IN OUR CONVERSATION TO
BREAK DOWN THIS STIGMA THAT
KEEP PEOPLE FROM SEEKING HELP
AND WHEN PEOPLE SEEK THE HELP
WE MUST MAKE SURE DADDY CAN
EASILY GATHER BEHAVIOR HEALTH.
**** WHO CAN. RELIEVE SAFELITE
I URGE YOUR BIBLE. THANK YOU
MISTER Q. SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. MISS
WHICH YOU WOULD LIKE CO AUTHORS
ON THE FIRST ROLE. THIS WEEK'S
IS REQUESTING THAT THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
WATERS ON THE RESOLUTION. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK. WE'LL
CLOSE ROLE THERE SIXTY NINE CO
AUTHORS ADDED THIS TOO IS A
FISCAL ITEM WE WILL TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION CAR
CLUB ON THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WELL. ZERO TIE THAT
I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO THAT
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WE'RE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM FORTY ONE. BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM FORTY TWO. H. R.
FIFTY ONE I MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE
CLERK WILL READ. HOUSE
RESOLUTION FIFTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER AND
OTHERS REALTORS A BLACK WOMAN
EQUAL PAY DAY. THIS
KAMLAGER-DOVE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT HR FIFTY ONE IN HONOR
OF BLACK WOMEN'S EQUAL PAY DAY.
NEARLY FIFTY YEARS AFTER THE
FEDERAL EQUAL PAY ACT WOMEN ARE
STILL FIGHTING TO GET EQUAL PAY
FOR EQUAL WORK WE RECOGNIZE
WOMEN'S EQUAL PAY DAY IN APRIL
BECAUSE IT MARKS THE TIME WHEN
WOMEN ON AVERAGE. CATCH UP TO
THE WAGES PAID TO MEN FROM THE
PREVIOUS YEAR. BUT GROUPING ALL
WOMEN TOGETHER CAN BE
MISLEADING WOMEN OF COLOR
SUFFER THE GREATEST
CONSEQUENCES FROM PAY
DISCRIMINATION. WHILE THE
AVERAGE WOMAN MAKES EIGHTY
CENTS TO EVERY DOLLAR A MAN
EARNS BLACK WOMEN ONLY MAKE
ABOUT SIXTY ONE CENTS ON THE
DOLLAR. BLACK WOMEN'S EQUAL PAY
DAY IS ON AUGUST TWENTY SECOND
BECAUSE IT MAY TAKES BLACK
WOMEN ON AVERAGE EIGHT MONTHS
TO CATCH UP WITH THE EARNINGS
OF MEN FROM THE PREVIOUS YEAR.
80% BLACK WOMEN ARE THE PRIMARY
BREAD WINNERS WE REPRESENT 53%
OF THE BLACK LABOR FORCE BLACK
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES HAVE
SURGED BY ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FOUR PERCENT. AND WE ARE THE
MOST EDUCATED GROUP IN THE
UNITED STATES WITH WOMEN MAKING
UP 64% OF BLACK STUDENTS WHO
EARNED BACHELOR'S DEGREES. AND
YET TODAY MILLIONS OF BLACK
WOMEN IN OUR FAMILIES STRUGGLE
TO GET BY. A LIFETIME OF LOWER
PAY MEANS THAT BLACK WOMEN HAVE
LESS INCOME TO SAVE FOR OUR
EDUCATION OUR FAMILIES AND
RETIREMENT. OVER A FORTY YEAR
CAREER WOMEN OVER ALL LOSE FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS AS A
RESULT OF THE WAGE GAP WITH
WOMEN OF COLOR LOSING ALMOST
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
OUR HARD WORK IS UNDERVALUED
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF THE COLOR OF
OUR SKIN. SLAVERY AND JIM CROW
PERIODS CHARACTERIZED BY THE
EXPLOITATION OF BLACK WOMEN'S
PHYSICAL AND REPRODUCTIVE LABOR
SHAPED LABOR MARKET OUTCOMES
FOR BLACK WOMEN FOR DECADES IN
THE THIRTIES BLACK WOMEN WERE
PRIMARILY EMPLOYED AS
AGRICULTURE AND DOMESTIC
WORKERS AND AS LABOR MARKET
OPPORTUNITIES MATERIALIZED FOR
SOME WOMEN. RULES WERE ADAPTED
TO ENSURE THE DYNAMIC REMAINED
THE SAME LIKE THE PRACTICE OF
TIPPING WHICH EMERGED IN
RESISTANCE TO BLACK WORKERS
MOVING INTO FORMAL EMPLOYMENT
AND WAS USED TO AVOID PLAYING
PAYING BLACK AMERICANS FOR
THEIR LABOR. THE NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE SOCIAL SECURITY ACT
THE NATIONAL LABOR RELATIONS
ACT AND THE FAIR LABOR
STANDARDS ACT TRANSFORM THE
LABOR MARKET FOR SO MANY WHITE
WORKERS AND YET ALL EXCLUDED
DOMESTIC AN AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS FROM UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS A NATIONAL MINIMUM
WAGE AND A FORTY HOUR WORK
WEEK. TO NAME A FEW OF THE MANY
PROTECTIONS DENIED BLACK WOMEN
WORKERS. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS CONVENE THE PAY
EQUITY TASK FORCE TO FORM BEST
PRACTICES IN CLOSING THE PAY
GAP. THE COMMISSION FOUND THAT
EQUITABLE PAY POLICIES CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED SIMPLY AND WITHOUT
UNDUE COSTS IN BOTH THE PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE SECTORS. THE RACE
AND GENDER PAY GAP IS NOT A BUG
IN AMERICA'S ECONOMIC SYSTEM
IT'S A PRIME FEATURE. WE MUST
PERSIST IN ADDRESSING THESE
DISPARITIES NOT ONLY FOR BLACK
WOMEN IN OUR FAMILIES BUT FOR
OUR SOCIETY AT LARGE FAIR PAY
ENHANCES THE ECONOMY AND
REDUCES THE NEED FOR THE PUBLIC
SAFETY NET. WE WILL ALL BENEFIT
WHEN EVERY CALIFORNIAN RECEIVES
JUST AND EQUAL PAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON HR FIFTY ONE. THINGS
KAMLAGER-DOVE MISS THEM ON YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY I AM PROUD
SUPPORT OF HR FIFTY ONE
AUTHORED BY THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO AND
PRESENTED. BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS ANGELES AS HAS BEEN STATED
WE AS WOMEN HAVE FOUGHT FOR
DECADES TO BE PAID FAIRLY AND
EQUALLY FOR THE WORK WE DO. AND
YET THIS FIGHT AND SOME OF THE
GAINES WITNESSED ARE NOT
EQUALLY AMONGST ALL WOMEN IN
THE WORLD. WHEN A BLACK WOMEN
EARN SIXTY ONE CENTS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR IN COMPARISON TO THEIR
WHITE MALE COLLEAGUE FOR THE
SAME JOB. WE MUST TAKE A MOMENT
TO REFLECT ON WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES. AND HOW
MUCH WORK REMAINS TO BE DONE. A
MEMBER OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
AUTHORED THE TOUGHEST PAY
EQUITY BILL IN THE NATION AND
THE COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS CONVENE THE PAY
EQUITY TASK FORCE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE FOR
MEANINGFUL COMPLIANCE. TO WHAT
IS KNOWN AS THE FAIR PAY ACT IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR NEARLY TWO AND
A HALF YEARS INDUSTRY AND
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS WORK TO
CRAFT RESOURCES AND GUIDANCE.
FOR EMPLOYERS WHO SEEK TO
ENSURE PAY EQUITY WITHIN THEIR
COMPANIES AND TO ENSURE
EMPLOYEES UNDERSTAND THERE
RIGHT. THE COMMISSION LAUNCHED
HASHTAG EQUAL PAY CALIFORNIA AS
A JOINT PROJECT OF THE
COMMISSION AND THE FIRST
PARTNER. THIS YEAR AND HAS
ALREADY SEEN THIRTY CALIFORNIA
BASED CORPORATION SIGN ON TO
THE EQUAL PAY PLEDGE. ALL OF
THIS WORK IS IMPORTANT AND
IMPACTFUL BUT WE CAN ONLY MOVE
FORWARD AS WOMEN WHEN EVERY
WOMAN IS CONSIDERED I AM
THANKFUL TO MY COLLEAGUES FROM
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS THAT HAVE.
ALLOWED US TO HELP RAISE THIS
AWARENESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MS AMONG. THE SCENE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
KAMLAGER-DOVE YOU MAY CLOSE YOU
WISH THANK YOU I JUST WANNA LET
MY COLLEAGUES KNOW THAT NATIVE
AMERICANS WOMEN'S EQUAL PAY DAY
AND LATINA WOMEN'S EQUAL PAY
DAY IS LATER ON IN THE YEAR
WHICH JUST GOES TO SHOW YOU
THAT WE COLLECTIVELY HAVE MORE
WORK TO DO AS WE WORK TO FIGHT
FOR JUST AND EQUAL PAY FOR ALL
WOMEN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IBM. MS KAMLAGER-DOVE YOU
WERE REQUESTING CO AUTHORS ON
THE FIRST ROLE YES THANK YOU
MEMBERS THE FOR SHALL BE ABLE
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CLERK LIBERAL. ALL
MEMBERS OF THIS IS CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS ADDING HONEST CO
AUTHORS. THIS IS CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION. CLICK WELL
CLOSER ROLE THERE SIXTY EIGHT
CO AUTHORS ADDED. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE HOUSE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES HAVE
IT RESOLUTIONS STOPPED. MEMBERS
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM FORTY THREE.
H. R. FIFTY SEVEN BY MISS
WALDRON
. DE KLERK KOREA HOUSE
RESOLUTION FIFTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON OTHERS
RELATIVE TO WOMEN'S EQUALITY
DAY. MISS WALDRON YOU MAIL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS TO PRESENT HR FIFTY
SEVEN. WHICH IS DOUBLE SAYS
AUGUST TWENTY SIX AS WOMEN'S
EQUALITY DAY. NINETY NINE YEARS
AGO WOMEN WERE GRANTED EQUAL
VOTING RIGHTS THROUGH THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT. THE
WOMEN'S SUFFRAGE MOVEMENT WAS
SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE OF THE
PASSIONATE WOMEN AND MEN WHO
CAME TOGETHER TO PUSH FOR THIS
MUCH NEEDED CHANGE. HOWEVER
DESPITE THE MANY EFFORTS OF
POLICY MAKERS AND ADVOCATES
TOWARD ENSURING THE RIGHTS OF
WOMEN GENDER INEQUALITY STILL
PERSISTS IN MANY AREAS WE ARE
STILL WORKING TO ENSURE FAIR
PAY. AND EQUAL JOB
OPPORTUNITIES ACCESS TO
CHILDCARE AND FAMILY FRIENDLY
WORKPLACES. WE CELEBRATE
WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY EVERY YEAR
ON AUGUST TWENTY SIX AS A
SYMBOL OF THE CONTINUED FIGHT
FOR EQUAL RIGHTS FOR ALL
CITIZENS. JOIN US TODAY IN
RECOGNIZING AUGUST TWENTY SIX
AS WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY TO
CELEBRATE THE NINETY NINTH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ADOPTION OF
THE NINETEENTH AMENDMENT AND
IT'S A STARK IMPORTANCE TO
WOMEN'S RIGHTS IN THE PAST
PRESENT AND FUTURE. I'D LIKE TO
OPEN THE FIRST ROLE FOR CALL
AUTHORS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS WALDRON IS THE MONTH YOUR
RECORD. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO BRING RECOGNITION TO
HR FIFTY SEVEN RECOGNIZING
WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY. THIS
STATE WAS SELECTED TO
COMMEMORATE THE NINETEEN TWENTY
PASSAGE OF THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT TO THE CONSTITUTION
GRANTING WOMEN THE RIGHT TO
VOTE. THIS WAS THE CULMINATION
OF A MASSIVE PEACEFUL CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT BY WOMEN FOR
THE ADVANCEMENT OF WOMEN THAT
HAD ITS FORMAL BEGINNINGS IN
EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT AT THE
WORLD'S FIRST WOMEN'S RIGHTS
CONVENTION. IN SENECA FALLS IT
TOOK SEVENTY TWO YEARS FROM
THAT BEGINNING TO FINALLY
EARNED THE RIGHT TO VOTE. THE
OBSERVANCE OF WOMEN'S EQUALITY
DAY NOT ONLY COMMEMORATES THE
PASSAGE COMMEMORATES THE
PASSAGE OF THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT BUT ALSO CALLS TO
ATTENTION. TO WOMEN CONTINUING
THESE EFFORTS TO ADVANCE FULL
EQUALITY. TODAY'S I STAND
BEFORE YOU NINETY NINE YEARS
AFTER THE SIGNING OF THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT I AM PROUD
TO REFLECT ON WHAT WOMEN HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED WITH OUR VOTE BUT
ALSO ASKED THAT WE TAKE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT ON THE
WORK WE NEED TO DO. AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT ONLY A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX WOMEN
HAVE EVER SERVED IN OUR
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE. I WOULD
URGE EVERYONE TO REFLECT TODAY
ON HOW FAR WE HAVE COME AND HOW
FAR WE HAVE YET TO GO. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
EMMA. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION ON THE RESOLUTION
MISS WALDRON IS ASSN THAT THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS PURPLE OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS WISH THAT HONEST CO
AUTHORS. CISCO OTHERS IN THE
RESOLUTION. CLARK WELL. CLOSE
RATHER SIXTY EIGHT CO AUTHORS
ADDED AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON HOUSE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE AT THE RESOLUTION. IS
ADOPTED. I WAS VERY TO THE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE. THIS
IS FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR SB FOUR
NINETY FIVE. CORRECT SENATE
BILL FOR NINETY FIVE BY SENATOR
ALSO ANOTHER CYNICALLY BUT
SHALL CUSTODY MR STONE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
WHEN COURTS ARE MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT CHILD CUSTODY
AND VISITATION RIGHTS. THEIR
SAFETY AND THEIR WELFARE
HOWEVER THERE ARE SOMETIMES
WHEN THAT IS NOT THE ONLY
FACTOR WHAT SB FOUR NINETY FIVE
DOES IS PROHIBITS COURTS FROM
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT GENDER
IDENTITY GENDER EXPRESSION IN
THAT DECISION BECAUSE OF COURSE
SOMEONE'S GENDER IDENTITY AND
GENDER EXPRESSION HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH WHETHER OR NOT THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS THE BEST PERSON
TO LOVE AND CARE FOR THAT CHILD
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. ON SB FOUR NINETY FIVE.
THEY MISSED OUT ON SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLUB RURAL
WELL. DECIDE ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO THEM. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. IS THERE A VOTE. CLARK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
FIFTY ONE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEMS FORTY FIVE
THROUGH FORTY EIGHT TO PASS
RETAIN FILE ITEM FORTY NINE IS
SB SIX FORTY ONE. QUICKLY.
SENATE BILL SIX FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR ALLEN ACCOLADE TO
ELECTIONS. MR BERMAN YOU. I
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES SB SIX
FORTY ONE WILL EXTEND THE
TIMELINE FOR SPECIAL ELECTION
CONSOLIDATION FROM ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY TO TWO HUNDRED DAYS
FOLLOWING THE ELECTION
PROCLAMATION OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL DECADES THERE HAVE BEEN
A PROLIFERATION OF SPECIAL
ACTIONS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
HOWEVER THERE IS CURRENTLY A
SHORT WINDOW OF ONLY A FEW
WEEKS WHICH SPECIAL ELECTIONS
CAN OCCUR THIS BILL GIVES THE
GOVERNOR MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
WORK WITH LOCAL COUNTIES TO
DETERMINE THE BEST DAY FOR
SPECIAL ELECTIONS INCREASING
THE LIKELIHOOD THAT A SPECIAL
ELECTION CAN BE CONDUCTED
SIMULTANEOUSLY WITH THE
REGULARLY SCHEDULED ELECTION IN
THE JURISDICTION. RESULTING IN
INCREASED VOTER TURN OUT AND
COST SAVINGS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
BERMAN. SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ADAM CLERK LOCAL
THE ROLE. THESE ARE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBER SERVICE ARE THE. CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE
FIFTY SEVEN. NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FOR THE PAST
RETAIN A FALLEN FIFTY FILE ITEM
FIFTY ONE IS SB TWO TO THREE.
CORPORATE SENATE BILL TWO
TWENTY THREE BY SENATOR HILL
ANOTHER RECYCLING THE PEOPLE
HEALTH MISS SMITH. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
PRESENTING SB TWO TWENTY THREE
JUDGES ACT ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
HEALTH AS A FOLLOW UP TO SB
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN WHICH
PASSED OUT OF THE LEGISLATURE
LAST SESSION. THIS MEASURE WILL
HELP STUDENTS WITH SEVERE
MEDICAL DISABILITIES SUCH AS AN
EPILEPSY OR OTHER SEIZURE
SEIZURE DISORDERS TO ATTEND
SCHOOL. THE ONLY MEDICATION
THAT WORKS FOR SOME OF THESE
STUDENTS IS MEDICAL CANNABIS.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW A PARENT
OR GUARDIAN TO COME ONTO CAMPUS
TO ADMINISTER MEDICAL CANNABIS
TO THEM. IN NON SMOKING AND NON
PEIPING FORMS. MANY OF THESE
STUDENTS NEED TO TAKE A DOSE OF
MEDICAL CANNOT CANNABIS AT
REGULAR INTERVALS WHICH OFTEN
OCCUR DURING SCHOOL HOURS.
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT ALLOW ANY
FORM OF CANNABIS ON SCHOOL
GROUNDS THESE STUDENTS MUST BE
PICKED UP BY THEIR PARENTS AND
TAKING ONE THOUSAND FEET OFF
CAMPUS IN ORDER TO RECEIVE
THEIR TREATMENT DOES WHICH IS
OFTEN VERY DISRUPTIVE TO THEIR
LEARNING AND RESULT IN A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT. OF LOS
CLASS TIME. SB TWO TO THREE
WILL ALLOW THE GOVERNING BOARD
OF THE K. TWELVE SCHOOL
DISTRICT COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION OR CHARTER SCHOOL TO
CHOOSE WHETHER TO ADOPT THIS
POLICY. IT IS NOT A STATE
MANDATE. DISTRICTS AND COUNTIES
THAT OFTEN CAN OPT OUT FOR ANY
REASON INCLUDING IF FEDERAL
FUNDING IS PUT AT RISK AS A
RESULT OF THIS POLICY. SB TWO
TO THREE REQUIRES THE STUDENT
TO BE A QUALIFIED MEDICAL
CANNABIS PATIENT WITH A
DOCTOR'S RECOMMENDATION.
TYPICALLY THEY ADMIT THE
MEDICINE IS ADMINISTERED BY A
PARENT AS OIL CAPSULES TEACHERS
LIQUIDS OR TOPICAL CREAMS. THIS
BILL ALSO REQUIRES THAT A
PARENT MUST GIVE THE SCHOOL A
COPY OF THEIR CHILD'S MEDICAL
CANNABIS RECOMMENDATIONS TO
KEEP ON FILE. SIGN IN WHEN THEY
COME ON CAMPUS NOT DISRUPT THE
EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT AND
TAKE ALL CANNABIS FROM SCHOOL
GROUNDS AFTER ADMINISTRATION.
WASHINGTON COLORADO FLORIDA
MAINE NEW JERSEY AND NEW MEXICO
HAVE ALL PASSED LEGISLATION
ALLOWING STUDENTS TO USE
MEDICAL CANNABIS ON CAMPUSES.
THIS BILL ENJOYS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU MISS
WITH MS GONZALEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. HI I RISE IN AND
FORTUNATE OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL I DID VOTE FOR IT. IN
JUDICIARY FOR HOPES OF THINGS
BEING FIGURED OUT THAT'S A
SECOND YEAR I'VE KIND OF DONE
THIS DANCE WITH WITH SENATOR
FROM. NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SAN
MATTEO SAN MATTEO I'M SORRY SIR.
MY CONCERN IS THIS IN AYE AYE
AYE I'M TORN I REALLY KIND OF
WANT THIS BILL TO PASS BECAUSE
THE FAMILIES WHO PRESENTED
THEIR STORIES IT WAS SO
COMPELLING AND ARE ACTING VERY
RESPONSIBLY AND THEY'RE WORKING
WITH PEDIATRICIANS AND
SPECIALIST ON THE DOSAGE AND IN
THESE FAMILIES ARE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING RIGHT NAY OF COURSE
UNDER THESE CIRCUMSTANCES
SHOULD BE ABLE TO GO TO SCHOOL
IN MINISTER IT. MY PROBLEM IS
THIS IN ONE I'M GONNA BRING UP
ON THIS FLOOR IN SUGGEST WE
LOOK AT FIGURING OUT A WAY TO
FIX THIS THE MEDICINAL PROCESS
FOR CHILDREN IS NOT WELL
DEFINED YOU JUST NEED TO GET
THEM A CARD THERE IS NOTHING
ARE STATURE LAW THAT REQUIRES A
PARENT TO BE WORKING WITH THE
SPECIALIST TO BE WORKING WITH A
PEDIATRICIAN FOR THE EXACT
DOSAGE AND I UNDERSTAND THEIR
CONCERNS WITH YOU MAY AND
PUTTING THEIR THEIR MEMBERS AT
RISK. IN AND KIND OF
FORMALIZING THAT RELATIONSHIP
BUT IT DOES WORRY ME THAT WERE
ALLOWING FOR THE THAT THE
MEDICATION OF CHILDREN REALLY
TO BE DETERMINED BY THEIR
PARENTS WHICH SOME PEOPLE MIGHT
FEEL COMFORTABLE ABOUT I THINK
THERE IS POSSIBILITY FOR ABUSE
AND SO FOR THAT REASON I WON'T
BE SUPPORTING THIS TODAY AND I
HIGHLY ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO AT IT
ESPECIALLY SO MANY OF YOU WORK
ON CANNABIS ISSUES IN AND HAVE
A STRONGER BACKGROUND AND
MEDICINAL MARIJUANA. BUT I
THINK WE HAVE TO IF WE'RE GOING
TO TRULY TREAT IT LIKE A
MEDICINE AND WE BELIEVE IN ALL
THE GREAT THINGS THEY CAN DO
AND I FOR ONE DO I THINK WE
HAVE TO HAVE START TO HAVE SOME
STANDARDS AND. GUIDELINES BY
WHICH WE MEDICAID CHILDREN.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ. MR
MURATSUCHI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I. ALSO
WANTED TO EXPRESS MY MIXED
FEELINGS ABOUT THIS BILL YOU
KNOW GENERALLY I'M IN FULL
SUPPORT OF. MEDICINAL MARIJUANA.
HOWEVER THIS BILL IS OPPOSED BY
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND ACCORDING TO
THEIR OPPOSITION THERE
INDICATING THAT. ONE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S TOP PRIORITIES IS
TO PREVENT ANY YOUTH UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY ONE FROM
ACCESSING ANYTHING ALL TYPES OF
CANNABIS PRODUCTS. YOU KNOW I
FEEL THAT I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE MAY BE. SITUATIONS WHERE.
IN A LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS. MAY
WANT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR EXCEPTIONAL
SITUATIONS HOWEVER IN AS A
PARENT I FEEL THAT THIS IS
CROSSING WHAT SHOULD BE A
BRIGHT LINE IN KEEPING.
MARIJUANA CANNABIS PRODUCTS OUT
OF OUR SCHOOLS NOW I UNDERSTAND
WE LIVE IN THE REAL WORLD I
GREW UP IN SCHOOLS WHERE THERE
WERE PLENTY OF CANNABIS
PRODUCTS. AT AT MY SCHOOLS BUT-
IT CONCERNS ME THAT THAT YOU
KNOW WHEN WE- LEGALIZED
MARIJUANA. WE DID IT WITH THE
COMMITMENT TO HAVE BRIGHT LINES
A TO KEEP IT AWAY FROM KIDS AND
I'M CONCERNED THAT THIS IS
CROSSING THAT LINE. DR CHOI
YOUR RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
SPEAKER IN THE MEMBERS SIDE
RISE SAW IN OPPOSITION IN
OPPOSITION OF A AS PER YEAR A
TOTAL WITH THREE. WE ARE ALL
AWARE OF THE COMPASSIONATE TO
USE ACT OF A NINETEEN NINETY
SIX WHICH ALLOW PEOPLE TO USE
SOME MEDICINE ON A CANNABIS
ILLEGALLY. DUE TO THE FEDERAL
LAW THIS BILL IS SUCH A
VIOLATION OF OUR DRUG FREE
SCHOOL ZONE ACT WHICH IS
STRIVES TO KEEP OUR SCHOOLS
DRUG FREE. WHILE I AGREE THAT
THAT IS IMPORTANT TO THINK
ABOUT THE CHILDREN WHO ARE IN
NEED OF A MEDICINAL CANNABIS WE
MUST ALSO THINK OF THOSE SO
CHILDREN NOT PRESCRIBE THE
MEDICINE OR CANNABIS. THAT ARE
AFFECTED THE THROUGH A SECOND
THAT THE SMALL. I AGREE THAT
THE WE NEED TO ORG ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE ABOUT THAT WE MUST DO IT.
IN A WAY THAT TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT THE OLDER CHILDREN. WHO
WILL BE OUR PRESENT THOUGHT WAS
SCHOOR CAMPUSES. FOR THIS
REASON SAW I RESPECT TO BE
ASKING FOR YOU AT NO FAULT
THANK YOU. MS Là M<c.cyan> YOUR</c>
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. AS A FORMER SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER BUT AS ALSO WHO
HAS HAD. AND WATCHED AS STUDENT
IN THE CLASSROOM GET A SEIZURE.
AND KNOW THAT THEY CANNOT
ACCESS ON MEDICATION BECAUSE OF
WHAT THE MEDICATION IS IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT THE BILL ONLY
ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO MAKE
THAT DECISION IN MOST. IN MOST
SCHOOL DISTRICTS POLICIES ARE
ALREADY ESTABLISHED THAT ANY
DRUG. THAT IS STUDENT NEEDS
INCLUDING TYLENOL SHOULD BE
WITH THE NURSES OFFICE OR
SHOULD BE IN AN OFFICE THAT CAN
ADMINISTER THE THIS. THOUSAND
FEET FROM THE SCHOOL SITE IS
VERY FAR FOR SOME CAMPUSES AND
IT DOES NOT GIVE ENOUGH TIME I
ASKED THAT WE ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO MAKE THIS IN THIS
DECISION THEMSELVES. AND ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT STUDENTS FOR
DIFFERENT REASONS HAVE MEDICAL
CONDITIONS THAT THIS CAN AID IT
IS VERY DIFFICULT TO BE IN A
CLASSROOM. AND WATCHES STUDENT
GO THREE SEIZURE. AND NOT BE
ABLE TO HELP THAT STUDENT
IMMEDIATELY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER MOORE DOCTOR QUIRK YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. I RISE IN
SUPPORT THEM ALSO A CO AUTHOR
AN SP TWO TO THREE I WILL POINT
OUT THAT THE BILL SAYS THERE
HAS TO BE A MEDICAL
RECOMMENDATION. AND I WILL ALSO
POINT OUT THAT CMA A CNA AND
OTHER MEDICAL ASSOCIATIONS ARE
NOT OPPOSED C. B. D. IN
PARTICULAR WHICH IS ONE OF THE-
A COMPOUND IT'S- OF MARIJUANA
HAS BEEN FOUND. TO HELP MANY
CHILDREN WITH SEIZURES AND SO
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. THAT
THEY GET ACCESS TO THIS AND-
THE WORLD ISN'T PERFECT WE NEED
THE. FEDS TO TAKE THEIR HEADS
OUT OF THE SAND SO DOCTORS
DON'T FEEL IF THEY RECOMMEND C.
B. D. FOR SEIZURE. SEIZURE THAT
THEY COULD BE AT PROSECUTED BY
THE FEDS RIGHT NOW IT'S A YEAR
TO YEAR THING AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT. YOU'RE GONNA LOSE YOUR
LICENSE SO WE NEED FOR SCHOOLS
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THIS I
BELIEVE IN THIS IMPERFECT WORLD
THERE ARE A NOT FOR. WELL I
WOULD SAY. WE'RE DOING THE BEST
WE CAN AND WE HAVE TO PREVENT
THOSE SEIZURES THANK YOU. THEY
GET A QUIRK DOCTOR WOULD
RECOGNIZE THANK MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL YOU MAY OR MAY NOT
REMEMBER LAST YEAR WE PASSED A
BILL. THAT WOULD CHANGE THE
COULD CALVET THE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES ACT FOR A MEDICATION
CALLED AT THE DIALECTS SHOULD
THE FTA ACTUALLY APPROVE THAT
WHICH THEY DID AFTER OUR
SESSION ENDED LAST YEAR NO EPIC
DIALECTS IS A CANNABIS
MEDICATION FOR SEIZURES IT IS
FORCE VERY SEVERE SEIZURES IN
CHILDREN AND SO THERE IS A
RECOGNIZED MEDICAL USE FOR THIS
AND I THINK THAT THAT AS WE
MOVE FORWARD I WOULD AGREE WITH
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
THAT WE DO NEED. ADDITIONAL
GUIDELINES WITH REGARDS TO
CHILDREN BUT THERE IS IN MY
MIND NO DOUBT THAT THIS IS
IMPORTANT WITH CHILDREN WITH
SEIZURES AND I SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WOULD. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
IS SMITH YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YEAR AND THEY GET MY COLLEAGUES
OR YOUR YOUR RESPECTFUL
CONSIDERATION OF THIS MEASURE
PARTICULARLY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO BRINGS UP A VERY GOOD
POINT. OF COURSE WE NEED
ADDITIONAL RESEARCH IN THIS
FIELD PARTICULARLY IF THIS
PROVES AS IT HAS FOR SO MANY
FAMILIES ALREADY TO BE A
THERAPY THAT IS VERY
PRACTICABLE FOR OUR OUR STATE'S
CHILDREN. BECAUSE AS ANY OF US
WHO ARE HERE WHO ARE PARENTS
KNOW RATHER THAN HAVE YOUR
CHILD GO THROUGH A LITANY OF
TESTING WITH ANTI PSYCHOTIC
MAGIC MEDICATION OR PSYCHIATRIC
OPTIONS. IF YOU FIND SOMETHING
THAT IS AS USABLE AND AS
AVAILABLE AS CB DE AND SOME OF
THE CANNABIS RELATED PRODUCTS
ARE NOW AND IT'S SUCCESSFUL IN
KEEPING YOUR CHILD IN THE STATE
WHERE THEY'RE NOT HAVING
SEIZURES. ANY PARENT IS GOING
TO CHOOSE THAT OPTION TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA
SHE AND I ARE BOTH SERVED ON
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION AND THEY STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AS IT
WILL EMPOWER THEM TO BE MAKING
DECISIONS. AT A LOCAL LEVEL IN
ORDER TO HELP OUT THE FAMILIES
THAT THEY SERVE SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS SMITH
AND WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS FOR THE START OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS OF SATIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A.
I WAS FORTY TWO KNOWS EIGHTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERSHIP
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK IN
THE FILE. THIS IS ON THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE.
FILE ITEM OF FORTY ONE. H. R.
FIFTY. BY THE SPEAKER CLERK
WILL READ HOUSE RESOLUTION
FIFTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RENDON
ANOTHER'S RELATIVE TO THE
RETIREMENT OF YOU DAWSON WILSON
IS SHE FOR COULD BE ASSEMBLY.
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS MEMBERS I
RISE TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR
HOUSE RESOLUTION FIFTY HONORING
CHIEF CLERK DOTSON WILSON ON
HIS RETIREMENT. I HAVE TO GET
THIS RIGHT BECAUSE THE FIRST
TIME I MADE A BILL PRESENTATION
ON THE FLOOR I ASK DOTS AND FOR
HIS HONEST FEEDBACK AFTERWARDS
AND HE'S- SAID I HADN'T BEEN
FULLY PREPARED. SO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT I'M THAT I GET
THIS ONE THAT I GET THIS ONE
RIGHT. I DON'T THINK ANY OF US
ARE FULLY PREPARED FOR DOTSON
WILSON'S RETIREMENT AS CHIEF
CLERK. HAVING PRESIDED HERE FOR
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS HE IS AN
INSTITUTION WITHIN OUR
INSTITUTION. IT IS MY JOB TO
SPEAKER TO TALK TO A NEWLY
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND I'VE- HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH A GOOD HALF
OF YOU. AND YOU OFTEN ASK ME
WHAT ADVICE YOU NEED TO SUCCEED
I ALWAYS TELL YOU TO GIVE DOTS
ON A CALL. AND TO SPEND TIME
WITH HIM. AND HE'S GOING TO
WANT TO CHANGE HIS CELL NUMBER
BECAUSE I'M GONNA KEEP TELLING.
EACH CLASS THAT COMES IN HERE.
FOR AS LONG AS I'M HERE TO
CONTINUE TO CALL. TO GET DOTS
IN A CALL. THE THING EVERYONE
WILL TELL YOU ABOUT DOTSON IS
THAT HE KNOWS EVERYTHING THAT
GOES ON UNDER THE DOME. IT'S
NOT JUST BECAUSE OF HIS HIS
POSITION IT'S NOT JUST BECAUSE
OF HIS LONGEVITY. IT IS BECAUSE
OF THE RELATIONSHIPS HE HAS
MADE THROUGHOUT THE BUILDING
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING. THAT
INCLUDES RELATIONSHIPS WITH
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHO HAVE
SERVED DURING HIS TIME AS CHIEF
QUIRK SO DON'T THINK ANY OF
YOUR SPECIAL. THE NUMBERS
XCELERATED AFTER TERM LIMITS IN
NINETEEN NINETY BUT ONE MAN
DOTSON WILLIAMS WAS ALSO WILSON
INSURED CONTINUITY WITH THIS
KNOWLEDGE OF HOW THE ASSEMBLY
WORKS HE HAS ALWAYS MADE SURE
WE ADHERE TO THE RULES. AND TWO
TRADITIONS HE IS MORE THAN A
FUNCTION WARY AND AN
INSTITUTION THOUGH. HE IS ALSO
SOMEONE WHO IS A NOTED TRACK
ATHLETE AT UCLA EVERY TIME MY
DAD COMES HERE HE AND MY DAD
TRIED TO STUMP ONE ANOTHER A
FEW SILLY SPORTS TRIVIA.
ANOTHER OCCASION MY WIFE AND I
WERE EATING WITH HER FAMILY AT
A SUSHI RESTAURANT. I STEPPED
AWAY FROM THE TABLE I CAME BACK
AND DOTSON WAS SITTING WHERE I
HAD SAT. WHERE I HAD BEEN
SITTING IN HE WAS REGALING THE
WHOLE FAMILY WITH STORIES.
ABOUT HIS HIS TIME IN
SACRAMENTO. HIS FAMILY HISTORY
INCLUDES HIS MOTHER USING
UNCONVENTIONAL PRACTICES TO BY
THE FAMILY HOME. IN AN ERA OF
REAL ESTATE DISCRIMINATION. HIS
MOTHER WAS ALSO A PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER IN BERKELEY OR ONE OF
HER FIRST GRADE STUDENTS WITH
KAMILLA HARRIS. AND BECAUSE ALL
OF YOU WANTED TO KNOW THE IAN
NATIONAL IN FRONT OF HIS NAME
ON THE DAILY FILE STANDS FOR
EDWARD. THERE IS SO MUCH MORE
TO SAY ABOUT DOTSON WILSON AND
I KNOW YOU WILL ALL BE HERE ON
THURSDAY WHEN WE'LL ALL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
SPEAK ABOUT DOTSON AND HONOR
HIM. AGAIN BUT FOR NOW I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE FOR HR FIFTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MISS
WALDRON. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. IT'S WITH
GREAT PLEASURE THAT I
ACKNOWLEDGE STOCKS AND WILSON
AND HIS IMPRESSIVE LEGACY ON
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR THIS
AFTERNOON. THROUGH HIS MORE
THAN FORTY YEARS OF PUBLIC
SERVICE MISTER WILSON THE SHOWN
A KEEN UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
DECISIONS MADE IN THIS BUILDING
AFFECT AN IMPACT THE LIVES OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS. THAT
UNDERSTANDING IS WHAT MAKES HIM
SUCH A SKILLED PARLIAMENTARIAN
AND SUCH A GENTLEMAN. WHILE I
CAN'T SAY I AGREE WITH EVERY
SINGLE DECISION THAT WE HAVE ON
THE FLOOR. WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT HE APPLIED THE RULES
FAIRLY AND HONESTLY. TO MY
GREAT FORTUNE I WAS ABLE TO
SPEND TIME WITH DOTSON. IN MY
THREE YEAR TENURE AS MINORITY
FLOOR LEADER. AND HIS ROLE AS
CHIEF CLERK HE SHARED HIS
COMBINE PERSONALITY HIS DEEP
KNOWLEDGE AND HIS PASSION FOR
CREATING CHANGE AND I AM
THANKFUL FOR THE SUPPORT AND
GUIDANCE HE SHARED. DURING THE
TIME WE WORK TOGETHER. FROM
BRING BRINGING MY STAFF A FEW
TIMES TO SEE THE INNER WORKINGS
OF THE CLERK'S OFFICE. TO
VISITING AND GROSSING EN ROUTE
AND ROLLING SO WE CAN ALL SEE
WHERE THE BILLS GO AFTER WE
VOTE ON THEM. HE AND HIS STAFF
WERE ALWAYS HAPPY TO HAVE US.
AND NOT ALL INFLUENCES ARE
OBVIOUS MISTER WILSON USUALLY
WORK BEHIND THE SCENES AND
PREVENTED PROBLEMS BEFORE THEY
STARTED AS OUR FLOOR LEADERSHIP
TEAMS ALL KNOW A LOT GOES ON
BEHIND THE SCENES AS WE TRY TO
HAVE A SMOOTH. OPERATION HERE
ON THE FLOOR. WE WILL MISS HIS
VALUE AND HISTORICAL KNOWLEDGE
AS HE LEADS US FOR THE NEXT
CHAPTER IN HIS LIFE. I CAN I
CAN SPEAK FOR EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM WHEN I SAY HE WILL BE
MISSED. FOR BOTH HIS EXPERTISE
AND AS A FRIEND NO ONE IS MORE
DESERVING OF RELAXING DAYS
FILLED WITH FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
CONGRATULATIONS ON A
DISTINGUISHED CAREER AND BEST
WISHES FOR  HAPPY RETIREMENT I
DON'T KNOW HOW WILL FILL YOUR
SHOES YOU ARE AN INSTITUTION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
WALDRON THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. MISTER SPEAKER YOU
WOULD LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION IS THAT CORRECT.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS. THIS IS CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION
. THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS. YEAH
. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE
SEVENTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS ADDED
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
. MEMBERS
WE DON'T NORMALLY ALLOW CLAUSE
BEFORE THE VOTE HAS BEEN TAKEN.
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE. ON
THE HOUSE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE HI OPPOSED SAY
NAY. THE AYES HAVE IT THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
AS THE SPEAKER NOTED. THE
ASSEMBLY WILL HOLD A SPECIAL
CEREMONY TO HONOR MISTER E.
DOTSON WILSON IN THIS ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER. THIS THURSDAY AUGUST
TWENTY NINE
. EVERYWHERE BACK ON
THE FILE. SEVEN THIRD READING
FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO. THROUGH
FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX PASS RETAIN.
WE ARE FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN AS
J. R. FIVE. QUICKLY. SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION FIVE BY SERVER
BILL ANOTHER'S RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE MR FRAZIER THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS STR
FIVE URGES CONGRESS AND THE
PRESIDENT TO WORK TOGETHER TO
ENACT BIPARTISAN FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
LEGISLATION. WE HAVE MADE
HISTORIC GAINES TOWARDS FUNDING
ARE CRUMBLING ROADS AND BRIDGES
BUT INVESTMENT IS STILL LACKING.
WE NEED INVEST IN OUR HIGHWAYS
TO SUPPORT GOODS MOVEMENT IS A
KEY DRIVER OF OUR ECONOMY.
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS ARE VITAL TO PUBLIC
SAFETY AND ECONOMIC GROWTH AND
PROVIDE GOOD PAYING JOBS.
EXPANSION OF PARATRANSIT
SERVICES FOR THE ELDERLY ELDER
LEE AND THE SPECIAL NEEDS
POPULATIONS ARE AS CRITICAL AS
WELL. I DO WANT TO MAKE ONE
POINT VERY VERY CLEAR. THIS
RESOLUTION HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH PROPOSING RAISING TAXES.
RATHER FOR S. J. R. FIVE SIMPLY
URGES THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
SERVE AS FUNDING PARTNERS AND
pINFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE
SUFFICIENT TO ADEQUATELY A
SYSTEM FUNDING THE NATION IN
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT ABOUT. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT ICE FORTY
SIX NO SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP THOSE
ITEMS WITH AMENDMENTS ON THE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE.
AMENDMENTS ONLY. WE WILL MOVE
TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX. I
DON'T SEE MR GREY WE WILL
THERE'S MISTER GRANT. THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX SB TWENTY
ONE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CLERK READ WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL TWENTY
ONE WITH A MEMBERS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY. MISTER
RIGHT I AM A SPEAKER MEMBERS
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY LINE THE
BILL WOULD CHANGES MADE BY THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. NAME IS
GRACIE NO DISCUSSION BAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED A NAME. THE I. SEVENTY
MEMBERS SERVED OPTED THE BILLS
UP TO PRINT. AND BACK ON FILE
FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO IS SB ONE
EIGHTY FIVE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CORKERY WITH MATH
SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTY FIVE THE
MINUTES BY SIMPLY MEMBER WOULD.
DOCTOR WHAT ARE THE AMENDMENTS
THANK MISTER SPEAKER MEMBER
SAYS BE ONE EIGHTY FIVE IS THE
TRUTH IN LABELING AND
TRANSPARENCY BILL. THE
AMENDMENTS ARE RESPONSIVE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. TO MAKE
MINOR TECHNICAL CHANGES
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD SEE NO
DISCUSSION AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED.
BILLS OUT TO PRINTING BACK ON
FILE. WE WILL MOVE AHEAD TO
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTEEN. SB
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENT CORKERY
WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN COMMITMENTS
BY SOME REMEMBER EGGMAN. DOCTOR
EGGMAN ON THE MINUTES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SPEAKER MEMBERS SB
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN IS BACK WITH
SOME CHAP DURING AMENDMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU DOCTOR AYMAN SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES
HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS AT THE PRINTER
BACK ON FILE
. MISTER CALDERON.
YOUR RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE
REMOVE ITEM ONE THIRTY NINE SB
SIX OF THE SIX HUESO FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE CLERK
WILL NOTE. MEMBERS I BELIEVE WE
HAVE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE CITY
MEMBER WISH REMOVE AN ITEM FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING
HEARING ON THE CLERK WILL READ.
SECOND EXEC HELLER. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SIXTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO GOLD STAR
MOTHERS AND FAMILIES THING. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ROLE AND TELL A
VOTE I SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
FOR THE LAST. MEMBERS WE ARE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY AUGUST
TWENTY SEVENTH CHECK IN SESSION
WEDNESDAY AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY
AUGUST TWENTY NINTH CHECK IN
SESSION FRIDAY AUGUST THIRTIETH
FLOOR SESSION IS AT NINE AM. IN
THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION. I'M
CALL IS LIFTED. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
TWO GERMANS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR
. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS WHERE A GERMAN TO MEMORY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF OF THE FLOOR. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS FOR GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY. MR GLORIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE HIS AFTERNOON
TO ASK THAT OUR ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED THE MEMORY OF DANIEL
VERBAL A LOVING HUSBAND BROTHER
AND RESPECTED MEMBER SAN
DIEGO'S HOSPITALITY COMMUNITY
WHO PASSED AWAY ON AUGUST
THIRTEENTH. AT JUST FIFTY FOUR
YEARS OLD. DAN WAS A VERY
IMPORTANT MEMBER OF THE SAN
DIEGO COMMUNITY. IT WAS HARD
WORK AND DILIGENCE HE CLIMBED
THE RANKS OF EVANS HOTELS AND
WAS RECOGNIZED ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS FOR HIS CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE BETTERMENT OF SAN
DIEGO'S. IN TOURISM INDUSTRY.
OUTSIDE OF HIS DAY TO DAY WORK
HE WAS DEEPLY INVOLVED IN HIS
COMMUNITY PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON
OR CHARITABLE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SUPPORT SAN DIEGO'S LGBT
Q. COMMUNITY. DâN SERVED AS A
FOUNDING BOARD MEMBER AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE ROBINS ON
FOUNDATION WHICH HONORS THE
LIFE. OF HIS CLOSE FRIEND ROB
WHO DIED UNEXPECTEDLY AT AN
EARLY AGE. IT RAISES MONEY TO
PROVIDE COMMUNITY GRANTS TO
SUPPORT THOSE IN NEED. OVER ITS
YEARS OF EXISTENCE DEPENDS ON
FOUNDATION HAS SPENT HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO HELP
VARIOUS SAN DIEGANS. THAT WAS
ALL MADE POSSIBLE BECAUSE OF
DANCE CHARITABLE GIVING.
REGRETTABLY ON AUGUST
THIRTEENTH TWENTY NINETEEN
AFTER VALIANT AND FIGHT WITH A
RARE AND AGGRESSIVE FORM OF
CANCER THE END PASSED AWAY. IS
SURVIVED BY HIS HUSBAND STEVE
HIS SISTER MADELINE AND HER
SPOUSE SUSAN. A PERSON THAT
MISTER SPEAKER I NEED DâN I
KNEW HIM EXTREMELY WELL I KNEW
HIM FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS HE
WAS AN INCREDIBLE HUMAN BEING
POSITIVE FRIENDLY. ALWAYS WITH
A SMILE ON HIS FACE AN
INFECTIOUS LAUGH HE WOULD
ALWAYS HELP OTHERS WHEN I THINK
ABOUT DâN I THINK ABOUT OUR
LOCAL HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY
MISTER SPEAKER YOU'D UNDERSTAND
WHY HE WAS INCREDIBLE
AMBASSADOR. FOR AMERICA'S
FINEST CITY. I DâN ALWAYS BE
REMEMBERED FOR HIS POSITIVE
SPIRIT IS REASSURING PRESENCE
IN HIS GENUINE WILLINGNESS TO
HELP OTHERS HE WAS A GOOD MAN.
UNDOUBTEDLY DAN IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF THOSE AROUND HIM HE
LEFT THIS WORLD FAR FAR BETTER
THAN HE FOUND IT. AND SO I
WOULD GET ASKED WE ADJOURN
TODAY SESSION IN THE MEMORY OF
DâN VERBAL. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MISTER
GLORIA. AND YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZED FOR AN ADDITIONAL
GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE THIS
AFTERNOON TO ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN THE MEMORY ACROSS THE
MOLINA AND BECAUSE THEY PICK AN
EDUCATOR A FEMINIST AND
ACTIVIST A MENTOR AND A
PHILANTHROPIST WHO PASSED AWAY
ON AUGUST ELEVENTH AT THE AGE
OF NINETY ONE. GARCIA WAS BORN
IN MICHOACAN MEXICO IN NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT SHE WAS THE
GRANDDAUGHTER OF RENOWN
ACTIVIST AND POLITICAL FIGURE
ANDREAS MOLINA AND MAKE AS- IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN GRASSY
MOVED TO SAN DIEGO WITH HER
HUSBAND RICHARD ALLEN PIC. SHE
EARNED HER BACHELOR'S DEGREE
TEACHING CREDENTIAL AND A
MASTER'S DEGREE FROM SAN DIEGO
STATE UNIVERSITY. CROSS IT
TAUGHT AT A JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL
IN NATIONAL CITY AND EVENTUALLY
WENT ON TO BECOME A FACULTY
MEMBER AT MESA COLLEGE WHERE
SHE HELPED TO FOUND THE FIRST
CHICANO STUDIES PROGRAM. A FEW
YEARS LATER AS A MEMBER OF THE
FACULTY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNI SAN DIEGO SHE HELPED
FOUND THURGOOD MARSHALL COLLEGE.
GRASSO ALSO HELPED FOUND IMPACT
AND EARLY GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION FIGHTING FOR THE
CIVIL RIGHTS OF MEXICAN
AMERICANS IN SAN DIEGO AS WELL
AS THE COMMITTEE ON FEMMINILE
MANY COMMON US ENOUGH THE FIRST
NATIONAL FEMINIST CHICANA
ASSOCIATION. CHOOSE A PUBLISHED
AUTHOR RIGHT ABOUT THE HISTORY
OF INDIGENOUS WOMEN IN MEXICO.
SINCE OUR LOPEZ THE CURRENT
CHAIR OF THE CHICANO CHICANA
STUDIES DEPARTMENT AT MESA
COLLEGE RECENTLY SAID SHE WAS
SMALL IN STATURE BUT SHE WAS A
GIANT IN SO MANY OTHER WAYS.
AND I WOULD TESTIFY THAT IS A
TRUE STATEMENT CROSS IT WAS NOT
A TALL WOMAN BUT SHE WOULD
NEVER MISS HER IN A CROWDED
ROOM. FOR HER HARD WORK FOR
CONTRIBUTIONS AND FOR HER
ACTIVISM. GRASSY RECEIVED
NUMEROUS RECOGNITIONS INCLUDING
BEING NAMED CALIFORNIA'S WOMAN
OF THE YEAR IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO. AND WHAT I WOULD MULLIN
THE FIRST CLASS OF INDUCTEES
INTO CITY COUNTIES WOMEN'S HALL
OF FAME. ON AUGUST ELEVENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN GRASSY PASSED
AWAY IN MEXICO SURROUNDED BY
HER FAMILY. THIS SPEAKER
RECOGNITION OF GRASS IS
INCREDIBLE ACHIEVEMENTS YOU'D
BE INTERESTED TO KNOW THAT
SHE'S HAVING NO LESS THAN SIX
CELEBRATIONS OF LIFE ARE
SCHEDULED THROUGHOUT THE SAID
DAVID COMMUNITY THAT'S HOW BIG
A DEAL ACROSS EMILY TODAY PICK
IS TO AMERICA'S FINEST CITY.
DANIEL HER DAUGHTER ADELA AND
SON MILAN. GRASSY WILL ALWAYS
BE REMEMBERED AS AN IMPACTFUL
EDUCATOR AS A FIERCE ADVOCATE
FOR WOMEN'S EQUALITY INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES THE LGBT COMMUNITY
LABOR AND IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS SHE
TRULY DID AT ALL. UNDOUBTEDLY
GRASSY A MADE A POSITIVE
LASTING IMPACT BOTH IN SAN
DIEGO AND ALL AROUND THE WORLD
AND I WOULD ASK THAT WE ADJOURN
TODAY SESSION IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK
YOU MISTER GLORIA. ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WOULD PASS
RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUES SEEING AND HEARING
THE FOR THE BUSINESS OF READY
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN MR COOLEY MOVES DOCTOR
QUIRK SECONDS THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL FRIDAY AUGUST
THIRTIETH AT NINE AM. WE ARE
ADJOURNED
. THANK YOU AT
MAIENSCHEIN S. J. R. FIVE I TO
KNOW. VOTE CHANGE MAIENSCHEIN
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION FIVE
ALL RIGHT TO KNOW. THANK YOU
CHANGE. AB FIFTEEN FIFTEEN I TO
NOT VOTING. BUSH CHANGED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AB FIFTEEN FIFTEEN TO NOT
LOADING